a new story published by The Intercept
may be one of the biggest stories of Our
Lives I believe it I believe it maybe it
could be one of the biggest stories in
the world if not I'm sorry what is one
of the biggest stories in the world it
may be one of the biggest stories in the
history of the United States
according to new documents released by
The Intercept along with documents
revealed through a lawsuit filed by the
Missouri attorney general we now have
hard proof that Executives at Big tech
companies were colluding with DHS and
the FBI
to manufacture consent manipulate public
opinion censor certain information that
was deemed
hurtful to U.S financial institutions
and influence the elections in the way
they wanted
it's right there now I know that most of
us knew this was happening because we've
seen so many grains of sand forming that
heat but now we actually have leaked
text messages where you can see the DHS
talking with Microsoft and the Microsoft
exec saying we need to get more
companies on board with government
involvement the jayagare of Twitter was
directly meeting with the government
monthly according to the intercept no
wonder she got fired this is uh this is
huge stuff they said that the goal was
to manipulate information on racial
Justice Financial I mean this is crazy
so
yeah
and a week before the election no less I
kind of believe that this leak was
intentional because Elon musk's
acquisition of Twitter meant that he is
sitting on a trove of evidence it was
only a matter of time before he got it
and so they're basically thinking we
better get in front of this one
it was reported that the Biden
Administration was seeking to have a
National Security review of the Twitter
sale to Elon and then ultimately didn't
and I wonder if that was because they
knew something bad was going to happen
the information would be released and
now it is so now we know this is a
direct violation of the Constitution
and I and that's probably putting it
lightly some are calling it treason in
sedition considering you've got elements
of the government actively colluding
with people like vijayagade to
manipulate information to censor people
to violate their rights and manipulate
our elections literally they report one
of the reasons for this was the 2016
election fear about disinformation so
they started actively interfering here's
the crazy thing the Facebook login
portal for the government is still up we
can show you
that's how crazy it is we're going to
talk about that plus we have another
really ridiculous and insane story about
Paul Pelosi
and the conspiracy theories around what
really went down with his house because
you either believe that a q Anon
cultists tried to murder Nancy Pelosi
but only found Paul or you think that a
leftist black lives matter Pride uh flag
waving male prostitute was having a good
time with Paul Pelosi and I think both
stories are a bit over the top to be
clearly honest I I think we can we can
break down
if you're really if you're really
looking for what happened you can come
up with some reasonable explanations but
all that matters we need the information
we need the evidence we need the
surveillance footage so we'll get to
that before we get started my friends
head over to
liquidgoldlift.com and pick up your
BioTrust ageless multi collagen it's a
new URL you notice because this has
turmeric in it Ginger and uh and black
pepper and it's it's remarkably
delicious I put in my coffee it makes it
taste like some kind of Christmas spice
latte so the Angels multi collagen it's
collagen it's good for your skin your
bones your joints and turmeric is
purported to have tremendous
anti-inflammatory benefits especially
when combined with black pepper so I was
reading on like Mayo Clinic they're
saying that can help with arthritis pain
and it can also it's generally
anti-inflammatory so support the show
and head over to
liquidgoldlift.com and you will get a
60-day money-back guarantee you get
collagen and turmeric in one simple to
use Liquid Gold formula just put in your
drink you mix it up the healthy aging
support of five different types of
Premium collagen five key types of
college you need from four different
sources provides your body with the
age-defying power of organic turmeric
for every order today BioTrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it's non-GMO and free of
artificial colors flavors and
preservatives there's no clumping unlike
other collagen supplements you'll get
free shipping with every order and free
VIP live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust's Team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and their free e-report the 14
foods for amazing skin again this time
it is liquid goldlift.com check it out
and don't forget to don't forget to head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly we're gonna
have a members only show coming up for
you about 11 pm uncensored often a
little bit spicy not so family friendly
you don't miss it so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us to night to talk about this
and and more is Jake Beckett Tim great
to be with you thanks for having me
absolutely who are you good sir so I am
uh Jake Beckett from the great state of
Arkansas born and raised
um I played football for the University
of Arkansas back in the day back in the
Glory Days we had some good teams back
in those days played four years with the
Patriots uh stole a Super Bowl ring from
those guys stole it yeah stole it I was
uh I was lucky to be there I tell
everyone that it wasn't really a Tom
Brady and Bill Belichick who were the
real masters of the program it was it
was all me all you everybody knows it
was all everyone knows that
um and then I joined the army I spent
four years in the Army I was an entry
officer I went through Ranger school
deployed to Iraq and then I ran for U.S
Senate out of Arkansas came a bit short
this time but um you know I love to
to serve my state my country and you
know I want to be in the fight and
that's where I am right on well thanks
for hanging out that should be fun
thanks for having me we got Luke of
course hey guys Happy Halloween for the
record I I did have a Halloween costume
but it was a bit inappropriate for this
show if you want to see it you can on my
Twitter or Instagram Luke we are change
but I'm just wearing uh you know just a
regular JoJo Biden T-shirt If you get
the reference you know exactly what's
going on you are in the know and it's a
shirt of a big nose sniffing Biden you
could get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I am here thank you so much for
having me what's up everybody Ian
Crossland here sipping on a little bit
of this Liquid Gold Turmeric myself not
an advertisement just telling you it's
delicious that's delicious in case you
knew that uh good to see good to see you
what's up hey and I'm search.com I'm
also drinking this turmeric drink it is
rather good and uh Happy Halloween guys
hope you're feeling spooky I know I am
we had a Halloween contest earlier uh a
lot of really great costumes Carter
built a Mothman costume with a helmet
that had glowing eyes he ended up he
ended up winning but uh we're gonna have
that up tomorrow on the cast Castle Vlog
showing you all of the ridiculously
offensive like everybody just decided to
be offensive that it's like
that's what you do I guess so anyway
let's jump into this first story and
talk about the end of the world how
about that we have this from The
Intercept truth cops that's the headline
it's amazing leaked documents outline
Homeland Securities plans to police
disinformation I'm kind of surprised
they put it that lightly let me show you
this Twitter thread from Li Fang one of
the writers on this article he says
Doc's show Facebook and Twitter closely
collaborating with the Department of
Homeland Security and FBI 2 police
disinfo plans to expand censorship on
topics like withdrawal from Afghanistan
origins of coven info that undermines
trust in financial institutions FBI
agent Laura demlow was in communication
with Facebook that led to the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story in 2020 over the false allegation
that it was disinformation this year she
met with Twitter DHS to stress quote we
need a media infrastructure that is held
accountable
check this out Facebook and Twitter
created a special created special
portals for government to rapidly
request takedowns of content the portal
along with the NGO Partners used to
censor a wide range of content including
obvious parity accounts and content
disagreeing with government pandemic
policy that right there the government
doesn't like that you're dissenting was
colluding with Communications platforms
private collusion literal conspiracy to
silence you for your dissent
check this out there's text messages
right here the emails and documents show
close collaboration between DHS and
private sector Twitter's Vijaya got a
fired by Elon Musk last week met monthly
with DHS to discuss censorship plans
Microsoft exec texted DHS quote
platforms have to get comfortable with
government incredible
he says how does DHS justify its
evolving Mission from countering foreign
Terror groups to policing domestic
disinfo on social media leaked planning
docs show the agency argues false
information is a source of
radicalization and violence and of
course I really want you to see this
this right here is the Facebook URL for
the Facebook what is the portal is for
onboarded partner requests pertaining to
content issues on Facebook and Instagram
if you're an onboarded partner please
put in your request through this portal
still live the Facebook link for the
government to go and and tell Facebook
what to take down is still available
right now
this CR this is crazy this report's
actually ridiculously long hours reading
through it it's massive they mentioned
that they were policing information I'd
say like racial Justice for what reason
what justification would the government
have to do anything like this outright
it's subverting our elections especially
now they're saying it's ongoing and
Twitter Executives Facebook Microsoft
were meeting with the DHS to police what
they deem is dis disinformation
misinformation and Mal information and
uh to me this is far beyond that this is
a criminal conspiracy this is the
government colluding with big Tech
social media in order to make sure that
they have all the power all the
influence and anyone daring to just
question them not just about you know
racial justice issues as you mentioned
here but but the topics here that they
specifically decided to intervene on
make them look bad it was also
Afghanistan it was also the origin of
covet it was also a product that of
course they were working in colluding to
make a lot of people take and and when
you look at those issues what are those
issues have in common especially
Afghanistan they clearly show something
that the government got wrong they
clearly LED people down a wrong pathway
they clearly screwed the people of
Afghanistan over they they clearly
screwed all the soldiers there but they
wanted to control the narrative so they
could still look like they did something
good when they obviously did something
horrible and when you're doing that when
you when you're when you're creating
god-like power and authority to silence
people to censor people and to control
narratives we're talking about huge
amounts of power that that is almost
virtually impossible to to hold anyone
accountable to
I'm trying to elevate my perception to
the level of global governance like if
if I was in control of American Military
and and there's like a world because
like for me I'm an American citizen
American politics and and the
Constitution that's key if you violate
the constitution you're messing up but
then you elevate to the next level of
like I'm now in control of the military
and they in turn Japanese people during
World War II though they will violate
the constitution in times of great
stress to make sure that we all survive
I'm I I need this this is going to be
settling in I mean I had a feeling that
they've been doing this since you know
2012 2013 but it's just but I don't know
it has to happen yeah I've been
screaming about this this has been
happening for years and everyone's like
you know you can't really prove it it's
not happening because when you look at
all the censorship efforts that they
were they were doing throughout the
years it all made sense that this was
organized not for the benefit of big
Tech social media but for the benefit of
the people in charge in power and now we
have the documents now it's proven sorry
I cut you off no absolutely I mean it's
to me it's I I feel sorry for those who
still believe we have a truly private
sector because really this is the
government they're Outsourcing you know
their dirty work to these giant Tech
corporations and you know we saw it
during covid you know we we saw it I
think it really started during the 2016
elections you know because Trump I mean
Trump won in large part in my opinion
due to his influence on social media he
was able to
um you know go around the the corporate
Legacy Media you know go around that
distorting prism of their influence and
go directly to the people and they kind
of had this Rubicon this never again
moment we're not going to let this
happen again you know we can't let these
America First populist types go around
our you know geek keeping mechanism and
go straight to the voters and so that's
where it started in my opinion I'm sure
it happened before that but 2016 was
kind of the collective never again
moment and I think it was accelerated
through Trump's Administration
um you know they they they took it
exponentially uh you know higher during
covid during 2020 and it's just it's
really sad because there's so many
politicians and and people in the GOP
you know our leaders who are supposed to
be representing us at the highest level
who are still fighting the same battle
they were they were pretending to fight
back in the 80s you know it was a you
know a give and take on corporate tax
rates and you know we're the We're the
Party of small government and we're the
party of you know uh freedom of
Enterprise and that that that battle has
been lost and so now we're seeing this
terrifying Union of big government
tyranny and outsourced to these big Tech
corporations and nothing can be more
um you know subversive to Liberty and
you know until we recognize that until
we as a people and we as a you know
Republican party those on the right
until we just come to grips with that
new reality we're never going to be able
to even you know much less defeat it
even fight back against it take a look
at this in the story Trump signed uh
Trump signed it they say that the the uh
stepped up counter disinformation effort
began in 2018 following high profile
hacking incidents of U.S firms when
Congress passed and president Donald
Trump signed the cyber security and
infrastructure Security Agency act
forming a new wing of DHS
wow Trump trump probably he said hey it
sounds like a good idea to me I wonder
if you read it probably not probably not
he probably had some advisor just be
like this is good it's going to protect
our infrastructure and it was like make
sense to me and he signed off on it
little did he know that all of a sudden
now damning information that was bad
about say Joe Biden's family would be
suppressed because the FBI was going to
Facebook and being like look out for
this yes and not only that but but this
is specifically referencing this story
by The Intercept and these leaked
documents are specifically mentioning
the the hunter Biden story which they
even named the FBI agent in this story
that went to Facebook and said hey this
is disinformation you got to take this
down when the FBI knew that they were
lying through their teeth after their
interview with Tony bobolinski they knew
that the hunter Biden story was legit it
wasn't Russian disinformation but but
Trump signed into law what essentially
was a major component and part of him
getting kicked out of office which is
absolutely crazy uh and not only that
but but a lot of the nonsense that the
American people had to go through within
the last two and a half to three years
when it came to covid the lockdowns
small businesses being shut down they
were only able to get away with it
because they dominated the conversation
anyone speaking out against them would
be censored would be kicked offline
doctors would be kicked out of medical
boards would have their licenses taken
away for even questioning what was going
on here and now we're finding out that
was that was what the doj and the FBI
were making sure was happening because
now we're finding out that they were at
the head of making a lot of these
decisions pushing for censorship pushing
for disinformation not in in an alleged
fight against fighting it but in reality
they were really pushing it they no no
you said were they are did you say that
the portal is still active on Facebook
right now they specifically went to
Facebook and asked them to censor
specifically the hunter Biden story okay
then Mark Zuckerberg lied to Joe Rogan
yeah he said yes look they were not
specifically annoying or he didn't know
look at this there is a Facebook portal
where they can go and specifically say
take this down no no hold on to be
specific and to be very careful Mark
Zuckerberg may be the one time that the
FBI didn't have have to go through this
portal and they were talking a mark on
the phone maybe he was referring to some
very specific one and that's how it went
down you're not going to convince me
when Facebook has an active portal for
government takedown requests that they
went to Mark and said there may be a
story we can't tell you which one though
and then Mark Whit better take down this
Hunter Biden laptop story don't buy it
not when they when Facebook built them a
portal to specifically request takedowns
yeah and when you look at the story and
specifically the tweets they they
mentioned an FBI agent Laura Delma I I
uh delmo low demo and specifically
referencing the hunter Biden story to
the FBI to to Facebook right so so
they're mentioning it from all these
leaked documents it's more in our face
more than ever and I'm sure the story is
well sourced and I'm sure there are some
Within These institutions who are you
know on our side but you know to my to
to my mind I'm wondering where the where
is the right wing resistance inside
these institutions
and it's kind of like the dog that
didn't bark we're not seeing the kind of
organize resistance to the bite
Administration that we saw from these
institutions in permanent DC as during
the Trump Administration so that tells
me these these institutions they're
they're they're they're beyond being
salvaged they're not reformable and I
just don't I don't hear enough from
people who are in politics on our side
on on the right kind of the old right as
I say who truly grasped that who say
like you know there's no there's no
nipping around the edges of the FBI
there's no nipping around the edges of
the doj there's no nipping around the
edges of these of DHS because they are
they are in cahoots with with permanent
Washington with the left-wing media with
big Tech you know and until we
understand the power of that Union we
can't defeat it yeah you got to build
systems that are indiscernible that are
like um decentralized that are mesh
networks that aren't relying on
centralized services that run under the
radar because I don't think you mean
compete with global government military
force you mean like the lava bit uh
email servers Ian that's specifically
we're started that Edward Snowden was
using where the NSA came to and gave
them an official national security
letter saying shut up give us all your
information or you're going to jail the
lava bit story I actually interviewed
the founder a few years ago ladar
Levinson uh absolutely stood up to some
crazy Insanity when it came to the
federal government coming after him
trying to of course spy on
whistleblowers and he leaked that story
and he actually safeguarded a lot of
very important uh you know data and
information this is lava bit is an open
source encrypted Webmail service founded
in 2004 and it was 2013 the government
ordered it to turn over its SSL private
keys so that then there yeah I think the
service should not be holding on to the
private Keys those should be the only
the sender and receiver should have
those keys that's a big part of it I
want to say did I call it or did I call
it here's a tweet it's an excerpt from
that story in a March meeting Laura
demlo an FBI official warned the threat
of subversive information on social
media could undermine support for the US
government imagine that do you think
look I gotta imagine you're trying
really hard every day to undermine
support for the US government but uh
I'll keep reading Dem Lo according to
notes of the discussion attended by
senior Executives from Twitter and
JPMorgan Chase stressed that we need a
media infrastructure that is held
accountable this is what I was saying
that the reason Elon tried backing out
is because they showed him confidential
information saying we have these
Arrangements of the federal government
and you can't disclose it
and you now have to buy it and Elon
probably was like no way dude no wait
now maybe that's not the case but what I
did get right was that Twitter was
actively working with the government on
what they deemed to be National Security
issues albeit bunk once what may have
happened now because also I won't say I
I got 100 correct what may have happened
after this Elon Musk buys Twitter
now he's leaking information you guys
see this the evidence that they withheld
information on fraud or whatever he
posted this tweet of the guy being like
basically we're doing what elon's
accusing us of doing and the information
was withheld from the courts I think
Elon gets Twitter
the Obama I'm sorry the Biden well the
Biden Administration panics
they leaked this information because
they know Elon is now sitting on a trove
of evidence and he probably will publish
it or it will get leaked and they can't
control it anymore yeah he he knows how
the federal government manipulated the
the in the public landscape manipulated
the elections manipulated National
tragedies manipulated what happened in
Afghanistan manipulated what happened
with with covid that that's a treasure
Trove of information that he has as his
fingertips right now that could show us
the direct manipulation by government
the direct manipulation and interference
of government when it came to of course
destroying free speech in this country
and again I've been screaming about this
for years and everyone's always was
saying but it's a private company it's a
private company I still remember you
know even three years ago being on the
show and then there was a guest saying
but there's a private company they get
to do what they want and I was like
they're not a private company they were
never a private company they always had
connections with the federal government
they are a proxy of the U.S government
exactly and the special interests who
control the US government that actually
pull the strings of the bureaucrats
inside of Washington DC and then people
need to realize this is this is real
this is absolute real life crazy
conspiracy that that has turned out to
be true a week before the election let
me tell you guys
we hear from from the left the Democrats
they're like this election is could be
the death of democracy like if the
Republicans win the Republic is over
whatever well they don't say Republicans
say the death of democracy I genuinely
believe it this story got exposed
that this election very well may be a
battle for the soul of the Republic to
which
I don't even know if Republicans can
save it to be completely honest but
certainly Democrats are going to rip it
to shreds and the last line of defense
is going to be some of these Maga
Republicans who might actually push back
against this but let me put it this way
they started this campaign after the
2016 election
we then saw how the media was
manipulating we saw all of it we saw the
lies about Donald Trump constantly
social media censorship the Banning of
Alex Jones and milianopolis project
veritas
they are doing this specifically
because they want to manufacture consent
the Democrats have controlled Congress
since 2018. this has been ramping up
Trump signed the sisa act around 2018
with Democrats in control
if they retain control of Congress these
programs will manipulate and subvert
public discourse manufacture consent and
interfere with our elections
if there is not an effort in any way I
don't know if Republica I'm not saying
Republicans are guaranteed to do
anything about it but they're certainly
the only ones who are able to
if this is not if the Democrats win this
is going to ramp up tenfold and then
that's it but hold on I want to I want
to kind of question that a little bit
because it was Donald Trump who put this
into place right and if you're a
republican coming into power right that
that that's like a the Ring of Sauron
right here you have the ability to to
navigate and control speech online you
have the possibility to fortify
elections why would Republicans give out
that power because it consumes you
exactly yeah but why I don't I don't
trust the Republican party I mean not
the leadership there are good
Republicans there are good members and
they're good candidates running this
cycle but what I struggle with is you
know here we go again we've had wave
elections in this country before 1994
2010 2016 we had the trifecta you know
White House both both chambers of
Congress and here we are again we're
talking about another wave election well
where did those three previous wave
elections get us right here so what's
going to be different about it this time
you know if we take the house you know
we'll have Kevin McCarthy speaker if we
take the Senate we'll have Mitch
McConnell as majority leader and I'm not
saying it's a good thing to have the
Democrats in full control for two more
years but you know I just want to hear
how this is going to be different this
time I agree and what frustrates me to
no end is we we don't treat our voters
with respect we don't treat the
right-leaning people in this country our
constituents we don't have the humility
to look them in the eye and say hey yeah
what we've been doing has been failing
and we're going to try something
different I don't see them doing
anything different but that that's just
me that's my own perspective yeah I mean
there's there's Thomas Massey there's
Margaret Taylor green there's Rand Paul
there are great members they may if the
Republicans get in they may be able to
make some look it's the best chance we
got especially in the house there's some
great numbers on the house side the sin
is a different story but unless unless
your proposal Luke is I don't know vote
libertarian it's a unit party two head
it's it's two heads of the same snake at
the end of the day just we also have to
understand our our public opinion
matters on this what we say what we
think how we respond to this story how
we share this story absolutely matters
and I say that specifically because if
you remember not so long ago the Federal
Government tried to pass the
disinformation government board and they
had a disinformation czar that they were
putting forward essentially what they
were trying to do is codify what they
were doing in secret and then the wide
response to that was hell no are you
crazy you want to control speech in this
country you're insane but now we're
finding out oh yeah they were just doing
it the whole time but under a
sub-organization of the DHS under cisa
that's the organization that was doing
this that's the organization doing this
now so so we have to understand they're
only doing this in secret because that's
the only way that they could get away
with this right now we need more of a
bigger pushback and again left right I I
think we we shouldn't be consumed with
parties we shouldn't be consumed by
making Mass generalizations about
individuals based on their gang and
their affiliation we should focus on the
individual if an individual is good we
should support them if an individual
sucks and is a corporate distance as a
banker and is a little sellout status
shell that will screw you over
don't support that person I don't think
the solution is in the government though
I think that as always in the United
States it comes from the public the
private sector the people that are
willing to build systems that adhere to
the US Constitution the government's
there to protect us if things go wrong
um and I think social media in general
you're never going to be able to ask it
stop manipulating stop manipulating
things stop it's never going to stop
it's there for the world the problem
with free systems is they're easy to
manipulate they're easy to hijack so
that's one kind of flaw in the United
States freedom and democracy it lets
people come in and just twist it around
and say whatever they want and that's
red communism and spread
authoritarianism and so that's
oh oh I I think that uh oh anyway
continue yeah okay that's actually
actually one of the big conspiracy
theories of history is that
the British didn't actually surrender
the Revolutionary War they realized that
we were attempting to build a government
of foreign by the people and they said
whoa wait we can we can Finance control
of this of the of the colonies we don't
need to do anything and they really did
the central banks they warned us that
the central banks are more dangerous
than standing armies and
over the years they've tried this a
third one that they've installed in the
United States what was it Andrew Jackson
got shot after he broke up the second
one he did uh I don't just finished a
grade biography yeah I mean he was a
hero I mean imagine imagine abolishing
the federal bank and being in office
with a federal Surplus not a debt a
surplus I mean the big controversy in
his administration was had to distribute
the Surplus amongst the states imagine
that yeah imagine that and then they put
them on the 20 bill but but you're
talking about something here that's very
important here because this DHS board
this information board was also working
to of course make sure that information
wasn't being released that would
undermine our financial institutions
inside of the United States and Trust in
the financial institutions that
literally have bankrupted this country
it's not a recession It's a Robbery
what's happening right now with the
banks and what they've done to the
American public yeah they have to really
hate us I imagine like Ian Grant ragging
on the Federal Reserve 24 7 Luke as well
well how does this show exist some
people just want to end it all and
they'll be like take it down to burn it
to the ground but item not like that and
I'm one of like make a better system so
that we can transition away from the
Federal Reserve into like a
decentralized system of banking you know
the great thing about the Federal
Reserve is if someone robs it and takes
your money they'll cover it FDIC
Insurance like if if your bank if you
lose your bank card you can go get
another one with crypto if you lose your
keys all your crypto's gone forever you
have nothing if someone steals your
crypto out of your wallet you're you
have nothing yeah and there's no
recourse very dangerous for like the
common man I understand why there's
reticence but at the same time like it's
like pick your poison do you want Total
overarching Control authoritarianism or
do you want fully decentralized laissez
faire good luck out there lifestyle I
don't you know I don't maybe there's a
middle ground I probably want a middle
ground
um but who's going to be who would be in
control of the crypto wallets who would
be there to be like I'll make sure I'll
be the one that'll hold your keys for
you I think anything's better right now
than the current system we have now
where the government literally prints
money and just hands it to the richest
people in the world I I think
specifically the people who you know
promote the ESG score and use that kind
of Leverage and Power in order to push
woke nonsense onto people that that
should be pushed back on but again a lot
of it is coming from top down
corporations that get a lot of money
from the Federal Reserve I agree Luke
they should not be printing money and
giving it to the rich people richest
people in the world they should be
printing the money and giving it to me
then then I'd be totally okay with it
right you know just just give me the
money and then we're good because
because that's the way that's a lot of
people do think like that yeah that's
exactly how people think everybody
thinks that they have all the answers
and actually interestingly it tends to
be that the only answers come from
decentralization when everyone is
actually arguing and then the ideas that
make the most sense rise to the top and
then end up succeeding yeah there's like
value to like minimal centralization
like nodes of centralization all over
the price proliferative you know like
you don't want more than 60 people
involved in a note or something like
that but Tim what you're mentioning
right now is extremely important and
exactly what the Department of Homeland
Security is preventing they're
preventing the best ideas from going out
there they're preventing you know
Solutions they're preventing a lot of
this nonsense to be stopped in our lives
the pain and suffering that a lot of
people are going through is because of
the disinformation out there that they
are spewing actively and they are not
fighting it they are making sure that
they are codifying their agenda their
narrative which goes against you and
everyone else that's a great point
because you know that's the that was the
original concept of our government was a
very decentralized system with very
little uh you know power uh you know
vested in a central government the stage
could be the the incubators of Liberty
as I think someone one of the founders
said but of course the the powers that
be they understand that when people are
presented with you know the truth with
an opposing narrative they're attracted
to it you know it gets them thinking and
it reduces their own power so they have
to squash it and that's what we're
seeing with this story that's what we've
seen for the past six years you know on
steroids and it's it's never going to
stop until they feel the consequences
um you know of of of that decision
they've made well I think they're losing
control and this story is one element of
that but take a look at this from Daily
Mail Democrats demand a national
security investigation into Saudi
Arabia's stake in Twitter under Elon
Musk senator says Kingdom wants to
repress political speech and impact U.S
politics boy was that fast
the Saudi Prince has had a major stake
in Twitter for a very long time and not
a single one of these Psychopaths batted
and I until now with Elon Musk taking
over there there was a tweet and they
said how long until all of a sudden the
Democrats the butma private company
Democrats change their mind and say we
need regulation and insight and
oversight into this well here you go
yeah Robert Reich immediately with the
Elon thing like lit him on like not but
just set him off like Rob all of a
sudden now he's screaming about Elon
being an oligarch and we need to break
it up like he never mentioned that I
mean like Jack Dorsey wasn't yeah wait
until they find out about Tick Tock in
China wait until they find out about
Facebook and you know the Department of
Homeland Security so we just find out
what found out about right now again
this is clearly an attempt to punish
Elon Musk as he is presenting an
opportunity to fight back against all of
this nonsense and provide the best ideas
to rise to the top that's an idea that's
scaring the crap on the individuals who
have a monopoly on ignorance and
violence and that of course is the state
absolutely I mean the Saudi public
investment fund they've you know
publicly they've invested in this live
golf tour recently um you know they were
early investors in Uber you know the pif
has their hands in a lot of American
companies that's not really a new thing
um you know I found it interesting that
the doj launched a criminal
investigation into Tesla last week you
know coincidentally you know the the
week of the closing of the Twitter deal
into Tesla's you know full safe driving
or full self-driving capabilities so I
thought that timing was a bit more than
suspect that the week the Twitter deal
closes the doj launch is not a civil
investigation a criminal investigation
you know with potential jail time for uh
Tesla Executives can I can I just ask
everybody if they have their shot
glasses ready so I can say Civil War now
there you go should it give it should
have given you a second
um we had this tweet from Chris Murphy
says today I'm requesting the committee
on foreign investment which reviews
Acquisitions of U.S businesses by
foreign foreign buyers to conduct an
investigation into the National Security
implications of Saudi Arabia purchase of
Twitter he already had the stake in
Twitter and the reason why I bring up
those magic words is because when the
Democrats Overlook or defend things like
foreign influence in in our social media
platforms when it favors them and then
seek to weaponize the US government or
the doj when when all of a sudden that
power shifts
we can't function that way it's not it's
not possible for this country to exist
if one political party is actively
weaponizing law enforcement and the
weight of the federal government to
Target their political Rivals and that's
the only way it ever goes eventually
confidence shatters and it doesn't have
to be civil war like people charging at
each other that's not how the first
Civil War started it can be a peaceful
divorce would you consider what John
Slater what Gandhi did with India a
Civil War when they just stopped saying
sorry Britain just words passive
Disobedience we're not following it
could be that my beef with the national
divorce crowd I'm open to that concept
but I think that fundamentally
misunderstands the nature of the radical
left they they're never going to let red
States just go off and do their own
thing the left they they get off on
rubbing your nose in it they get off on
lording it over you as we're seeing now
like they they I mean like just look at
the I mean one example out of many I
mean look at
um you know look at the the way that the
the
um you know gay pride movement has
evolved over the past 20 30 40 years you
know it started as you know just you
know do what you want in your own
bedroom to civil unions to gay marriage
to the pride movement to transgender to
grooming children it's about rubbing it
in the faces of their political enemies
and so I just I think that the concept
that we're going to have this uh very
civil National divorce I think that's a
bit naive nothing civil but but at the
same time I agree with your point there
they are there are status that love to
tell people what to do but when you have
a centralized big Federal bureaucratic
government you have a vessel to allow
them to do that and I think we're seeing
the results of that and I think we're
seeing such uh you know divisiveness so
many people fighting each other because
of other people pushing their ideas onto
other individuals that's why I think a
decentralization a moving away from a
big federal government and enforcing
state governments could be something
like a peaceful divorce that that could
eventually happen in a way where it's
not really a divorce but at the same
time we don't have other people forcing
ideas onto other people because there's
no vessel in order to do it adequately
and that's why I would always argue
because I am for uh you know a you know
a peaceful divorce but a peaceful
divorce in a way that doesn't rely on
the federal government telling States
what to do states deciding for
themselves what they should be doing
themselves a limited federal government
regarding this Saudi this Saudi uh news
so this is the same investment Saudi
Investment that was in Twitter before
the acquisition yep and so here's what
happened this guy had a stake in Twitter
Elon went to existing major shareholders
and said will you keep your stake in so
that I can acquire this company and turn
it around at first he was lying nah get
out of here then he was like okay
this is by the way the same Saudi Prince
that has an investment with tens of
millions of dollars with Bill Gates why
is it why is it Bill Gates being
invested by investigated by the federal
government with his Saudi Arabian
collusion especially with his Chinese
collusion especially with his energy
companies especially with his nuclear
companies and his uh you know technology
that's helping the Chinese build uh new
weapons why isn't he being investigated
for that that there's a lot more at
stake with that than than Elon Musk
having a platform where people could now
finally talk to each other there's a big
difference between the two and obviously
this is a a clear action just to try to
hurt Elon Musk here exactly I mean if
you want to Outlaw All Foreign
investment in American companies yeah
let's have that conversation but it's
the selective enforcement that Senator
Murphy I mean obviously they're just
they're trying to
um you know attack a political enemy as
I see mosque is now a political enemy of
the left do you think it would be
righteous to ask the Saudi Prince to
recuse himself from the stock stock
Holdings of the American companies I
mean in general you think that's a wise
move he's invested in a lot of things in
the United States by the way right and I
mean are we going to single out this one
guy yeah I don't want to say I mean I
would say the Chinese I mean there there
is no Universe in which the Chinese
Communist Party should have any stake in
American companies period American
Farmland American companies like we
should treat them the way we used to
treat the USSR you know during the Cold
War and before that there was Zero
essentially zero trade relationship
between the American government and the
American Marketplace and the Soviet
Marketplace I think there could be some
trade but probably a lot of sanctions
are they an enemy or not I mean that's a
decision we have to make especially with
the uyghur camps that's why I think this
you know my fear is that sanctions could
eventually lead to escalation but do we
just ignore that's that's the tough
thing you got the interventionist versus
anti-interventionist and the lightest
form of it is is still like hey you're
doing a thing we don't like so we're
gonna sanction you but I'm telling you
in Arkansas you know like rural deep red
you know God's country or Arkansas we
have a lot of you know chinese-owned
land in our state we have a lot of
Chinese uh Chinese uh oligarchs and
Chinese government investment in our
state we had a a a Chinese native who
was a professor at the University of
Arkansas who was convicted of Espionage
on behalf of the CCP I mean it's
University of Arkansas let me ask you
why should any American citizen have to
compete with the finances of Chinese
oligarchs
if you're in Arkansas if you're in any
state and you want to buy a plot of land
to start a business or as a family why
are you competing in the market with a
foreign country it's a no-brainer I mean
that shouldn't even be a debate but like
but again like the free market you know
we just we we take these things to The
Logical extreme
um when it makes no rational sense I
feel like if a guy in like 1989 was
found committing Espionage against the
United States he was a professor the
Chinese was he in Chinese National he
was a Chinese National at the University
of Arkansas that would have been Global
yeah that would have been like Global
News it would have been on uh very
little coverage they wanted to create
animosity towards the Chinese which
right now I don't think they want to
create animosity towards the Chinese
seems like they're varying Cahoots that
they want to sell Taiwan to the Chinese
which by the way you could always sell
eastern Ukraine to the Russians if you
really want to go deep uh and just kind
of peacefully sell out I don't know I
don't think it's better than conflict so
I've always I've always been concerned
about the Saudi Prince's stake in
Twitter the difference between then and
now is then you had a public company
where he was he was pushing his
influence now you have Elon in full
control there's still a question of
whether or not this Saudi Prince is
saying to Elon like I gave you some of
this money so I expect favor something
like that
so the funny thing is you're like I
don't trust this Democrat to actually
have a legitimate investigation but I
think we should know exactly to what
degree this Society princess influence
on Twitter did Elon not pay the 44
billion then he got he got debt
financing he had others uh so this uh
Saudi Prince had this like nearly 2
billion piece of Twitter he said hold on
to that but give me control of the
company basically like loaning Elon
basically he might get a board seat of
some kind you know well Elon made
himself the sole board member for now
for now he said that's temporary yeah he
tweeted today that it's not going to be
for long that he is just the sole guy in
charge here right I wouldn't want that
pressure either sure and that's a
question like I mean should we allow a
foreign National to be you know a a
board member of either an American
private Corporation I mean that's I mean
that's it are we serious about this or
not
I don't I don't think it's I don't think
it's wise to to have foreign Nationals
if they can't run for office to own our
social networks that we use probably
more than especially how we've just
demonstrated they're not even like free
enterprise private companies anyway
they're federal government proxies yeah
are you against African-American owned
businesses like Twitter Ian is that what
you're trying to say here is that what
you guys are trying to say you caught me
you caught me no I fully support
African-American owned businesses I
think it's I think it's a it's it's it's
a very it's a it's a very complex
landscape it's not easy it's easy I'm
all for the free market but essentially
we don't have a free market we have
socialism for the super rich we have
government intervention with tax
incentives with with subsidies with with
them giving money from the poorest
people and giving it to the biggest
corporations that pay off the
politicians so we don't have a free
market system if we did I would think
that this system would of course fix
itself naturally uh with incentives and
and better business practices and better
competition but we don't have any of
that so I think before doing any before
making any laws first we got to get the
government out of business and the
business will fix it there's no real
free market it's a double speak term
like it's always been controlled either
by the people with the money or the
governments now when Andrew Jackson
ruled though well it was probably the
oligarchs at that point like the video
there's I mean robber barons yeah they
call it free market to appease the
masses and they're like don't worry it's
free but when you realize what's
happening it's controlled by the well
the same with Communism right yeah yeah
but look the idea of a free market is I
I don't think anyone if you believe in
the utopian view of things you're
probably wrong but in the general sense
of a free market it means that someone
from the lowest close class can find a
way to make money trade and eventually
become the upper echelon and gain
significant control over that system so
it's it's upward mobility in a system as
opposed to uh like a centralized Market
yeah or cash system yeah whenever you
have the government not involved in
private business businesses expand but
also quality of life expense but
whenever the government centralizes a
lot of the stuff as we've seen
throughout history this is this is not
always the case but but correlation
historically says less government more
economic freedom more prosperity for
human beings and then the opposite of
that is also true historically correct
because the free market I mean really
all it does is just harness you know
human nature and people's ability to fix
their problems people acting in their
own self-interest yes and really what I
we like I'm not attacking the free
market per se I'm attacking people
arbitraging the system you know gaming
it to essentially be you know
rent-seeking Behavior I mean that that's
what that's what these people are doing
by centralizing power and gaming the
free market to their own advantage
that's what I'm attacking but they're
not gaining a free market they're going
to the government and be like we want to
make sure we have no liability when we
give you this product uh we want to make
sure that no one could sue us if we hurt
people when we when you help us promote
for us and do our PR in making sure
people take our product that's not a
free market at all I know that's an
aberration it would originate with like
two guys selling apples and they're like
we're gonna compete whoever wants to buy
my apples at a cheaper price we'll do
this then eventually the two the two
apple sellers get together and they
collude and they're like yo let's set
the price of apples so then the
government comes in they're like no we
need a free market we're going to make
sure no one violates the law and then
the government sets the laws and sits
there as an Arbiter except now what
you're saying they're like giving people
subsidies not just that the federal
government is selling a product for the
benefit of big Pharma selling it
chilling it
and then using their Monopoly of
violence in a way to get protection no
matter what happens in the same
liability any liability which is crazy
that's not a free market guys I just
want to give a shout out considering the
episode and the subject matter to all of
the uh feds who are watching and
and uh feel free to you know set the
record straight if this stuff is not
correct or whatever you know you guys
can send emails and and send information
uh project Veritas I'm sure would be
really interested to hear what's really
going on behind the scenes so uh I bet a
lot of people are out of control in
their heads like what do we do what do
we I want to preserve American
constitutionalism we are globalizing it
totally down like a snowball and they're
like what do we do do I just go along
with what what's already been in place
like are we are we coagulating with the
Chinese becoming an Uber State they
don't believe in the Constitution
they believe that this country was
founded not in 1776 but in 1619 they
believe a whole bunch of insane
historical manipulations lies
misinterpretations to justify their
weird cult that's the scary thing so
when they're like in this in this uh in
the meeting report from the story from
The Intercept they're saying things like
people lack critical thinking skills
these days and that's a problem it's
funny because these people writing it
are the example of those who lack
critical thinking skills have you ever
stopped to ask yourself what the next
step in your actions is like you do a
thing what happens next they clearly
don't know they don't think about it
they just think they're smarter than you
they they read garbage fake news believe
it and then they say how come none of
these people believe the garbage that I
believe ah they must be stupid I know
let's censor information and and
manipulate can the public opinion these
people are just not smart enough it's
that it's that quote I always forget who
the guy is but he said something like if
the idea is that people aren't smart
enough to govern themselves so a smarter
person you know needs to control them
what makes that person smarter than
anybody else same problem well in the
old C.S Lewis quote I mean he said I'm
butchering it but he essentially said I
don't fear the Tyrant who wants to
torture me I fear the Tyrant who wants
to do something for my own good and
that's what the left is really doing
because I think deep in their hearts you
hook them up to an EKG lie detector they
would tell you they're doing this for
our own good they're censoring this for
our own good because we lack their
critical thinking skills that they have
in Spades and so that's what's so
terrifying is because I think obviously
there are some who are you know sadistic
and just want to hurt people but I think
there is a large portion of the left
that are truly doing this from in their
own work perspective a sense of justice
or a sense of you know do gooderism and
that that to me is so Insidious because
in their hearts they think they are
helping you by crushing your freedom
that's the low level guys in my opinion
I think they're sociopaths on top that
are absolutely calling the shot but
that's a lot that's an army of little
guys Bloomberg
said tax the poor you guys remember this
yep in that video he said because
they're too stupid I'm paraphrasing but
too stupid to know it's good for him so
if we take their money from them and
then tell them what they can buy they'll
be better off like when he when he
attacked sugar tax sugary drinks right
you know it's ever look I think sugary
drinks are really bad for you do I think
people should be allowed to have them
sure the problem is a culture where
people understand don't drink a liter of
Cola with your burger and but
Bloomberg's solution is no one should
like tax them punish them for doing it
that's the the dystopian authoritarian
ideology of these people now you see him
and his ilk and how they they take to
the rest of these platforms they think
you know what I'm smarter than you so
I'll be in control and the realities
they're not they're not and that's how
they would approach National divorce in
my mind they would say we can't let them
go their separate ways because we have
to help them
we we we we they would just go harm
themselves or harm others I think there
are a small percentage of people that
need to be guided that if they see two
opposing views that they'll they'll fall
for it but most a lot there's a huge
amount of people that are discernible
that can tell like you give me the
hunter Biden story and the evidence that
shows not well they they those people I
think actually wanted to to hide that
story
but I I they did there was polls showing
that it would it would have swayed and
impacted the election yes
yeah yeah it was it was sent yeah it was
a decisive censorship yeah it would have
changed our current political landscape
so this is the manipulation of public
perception and support the government
going to Big Tech and let me just come
on guys you know they're going to the
media I can tell you this definitively
how about this I was in Antalya Turkey I
think is the name of the uh of the city
is that is that it is so I want to check
look it up it's like the it's like a
Russian Resort town I guess and um I was
there with the guys from Vice
we are hanging out at uh they were doing
a talk it was all these rich people it
was an organization called wpp what is
it like wire and plastic product or
something like that who they own a major
portion and all of these companies are
around the world
and uh the CEO of ice explained how
after they went to North Korea they got
a call from the state department and
they had a conversation they talked
about all this stuff I don't think any
he said any Shane said anything about
them telling them what to report on but
they're they're in direct communication
over the stories they're doing and he
said something like he told them like
you got to talk to this guy in North
Korea because he was Western educated
there's like an opportunity so look man
birds of a feather flock together rich
and Powerful doesn't matter if you're in
Government doesn't matter if you run a
big company powerful Elites want to hang
out with powerful Elites that's why they
have big conferences every year and
they'll hang out with each other in
secret
um you know the story that we read in
the beginning of today's broadcast
extremely important and and and really
should make people aware of the larger
manipulation that the government is
conducting behind the closed doors but
if they're doing this to Big Tech social
media what is what do you think they're
doing to the corporate media what do you
think I'll I'll tell I'll tell you
you may think your favorite reporter is
actually a CIA agent or an FBI agent
with DHS no no no no that's not how it
works the way it works is there will be
a reporter young 24. fresh out of
college gets a job writing for like a
Blog and they're doing you know blog
articles or something
then all of a sudden
they publish this big scoop
their bosses are like whoa how'd you get
this story and have a source
within a few years they go from having
only a few thousand followers on Twitter
to reporting on major breaking stories
about Russia about social media
manipulation Russian disinformation
seemingly just dumping evidence
appearing on MSNBC and these other
channels all of a sudden they say look
we know that Donald Trump did this that
and this fueling the russiagate
narrative
the reality is there's a young
journalist who is stupid
and government actors and agents say hey
I'm going to be a source for you take a
look at this story and then the young
journalist gets all excited whoa this is
a huge scoop they go to their boss I got
a source in the government who just gave
me this document and they go whoa that's
an official U.S government document how
did you get that I have a source
how much money do you want next thing
you know they're being put on TV they're
getting a big salary bump and they're
major stars and news organizations why
because government a actors choose them
to be their conduit for releasing the
stories they want right and it's not
just like that it's a lot more Insidious
especially when you look at the 1975
Church committee meetings that literally
talked about how the intelligence
agencies were at the head of the major
broadcasting companies deciding what
stories they were going to cover and not
cover they were inside of The Newsroom
there's another famous journalist award
winning uh German reporter who worked
for some of the biggest Publications in
the world Udo of Ketty who came out and
said essentially they would send me
articles that I would just put my name
on that they would write for me I was
essentially just regurgitating what the
intelligence agencies wanted me to say
he died under of course mysterious
circumstances but but but again this
shows you that that the government has
the corporate media and it's obvious you
look at their reporting it's not
reporting it's just an establishment
press release they're not reporting on
anything they're they're essentially
trying to set up mind control in a way
that works to their benefit and that is
clear as day when you watch the
corporate media it's not as clear on
social media but it's becoming clearer
by the day when especially with the big
reveal that we just found out about
today when it came to the DHS hard
Segway we gotta talk about San Francisco
and Paul Pelosi because this one I was
reading so much stuff about Frozen
aren't familiar Nancy Pelosi's house was
broken into Paul Pelosi your husband
it's like two in the morning or whatever
he's in his underwear some guy
apparently breaks in they get into a
fight now a whole lot of information
comes out information is changing
everybody's trying to figure out what's
really going on the first story was that
like cops showed up and an unknown man
let him in and then they see you know
Paul Pelosi's fighting over a hammer
with this guy who then beats him then
they arrest the guy people are so so
here's what it breaks down to on the
left they say this guy posted Q Anon
conspiracy theories and he was a
radicalized trump supporter on the right
they're saying his house and this is
true has a pride flag a BLM flag and
like a unite against hate sign in the
window and the neighbors say they were
like hippie nudists hemp weaving
leftists
so there's that story the right that I'm
seeing the memes is that the guy who
attacked Paul was a gay prostitute the
glass on the door was broken from the
inside so the glass went outside and
that Paul Pelosi called the police and
said he was a friend
I think both of those stories go a
little too far I think it's fair to say
we don't know exactly what happened and
it's probably what what they're saying
about this guy being a cute cultist I
don't believe he was a registered Green
Party Guy but for before we get into it
I just want to say a couple things the
reason why I think Paul Pelosi said he
was a friend if you listen to the police
report uh the 911 dispatch call
you wake up in the morning some guy
breaks in your house he's not
immediately attacking you he says
where's Nancy what do you do do you say
start screaming and swinging at him love
your 82. so the story apparently is that
he went to his bathroom where his phone
was and then called the police my
assumption is that he told the guy oh
yeah yeah don't worry just wait right
here call the cops I I you know hey
there's a guy in my house and the cop
probably said do you know who he is and
he goes no and they said okay and then
Paul goes he's a friend he's waiting for
my wife
because you've got a crazy guy saying
you know what I'm saying crazy guy
sitting in front of you I don't think
Paul's head to the place out to the
place on the phone hi I just want to let
you know there's a guy I don't know in
my house and he's a friend I'm waiting
for my wife I think the police asked him
he said he probably said hey there's a
man in my house he's a friend he's
waiting for my wife the cops probably
said do you know this man he said no so
that this guy didn't hear what he was
saying I think that's entirely plausible
why is the glass on the outside because
the guy breaks it in and then pulls the
glass out to reach it and get the door
handle I don't know now I think the
story is not doesn't completely make
sense this guy was a leftist so the
story about him being a Q and on cultist
doesn't seem to make sense but I don't
know what do you guys think well did you
the official police reports say that
Paul called him a friend on the phone
with the cop yes uh I don't think ever
if there's a break-in that you would
tell the police your friend is over if a
crazy person broke in your house and
started telling you Ian that you needed
to help him right now to stop the Gnomes
who stole your spoons and you said would
you would you be like let me call the
police and they'll get us no no I turn
the fan on in the bathroom like there's
a psychopath in my living room like
maybe I wouldn't even I wouldn't lie to
lock the door to the bathroom close it
there there's there's also a couple
things that make you kind of wonder
what's going on here the Pelosi's are
some of the richest people in the world
and some of the most powerful and
influential people in the world that
have had their home targeted before by
political activists and they had no they
had no security they had no one there
was no it was their decision that they
they
intentionally like refused security yeah
that's what they're saying yes that's
that's absolutely just mind-boggling and
and especially yeah if you're doing
something Shady like like they do in
House of Cards which uh by the way uh
Bill Clinton said is uh 99 accurate
um maybe then I would understand that
but there's also another another thing
that happened here specifically with the
political reporting that police told
them that there was an unknown person
that let them in political is now
reporting that this is a baseless claim
when they originally reported on it now
I want to say I want to say this guys
all of this the whole story something
doesn't add up that's clear as day right
yeah it is a good point if he was able
to go into his bathroom and close the
door but where his phone was charging we
don't know why I mean and where's the
body cam footage I mean but it's it's
early it's early right here's what I
want to say though I want to say I want
to say this
I think the gay prostitute narrative is
the trick is a trick because once
everyone starts posting memes about this
crazy story about a leftist gay
prostitute it makes any regular person
be like what yeah get Audi it's
ridiculous
a break-in sounds plausible they're
trying to turn the story about a
break-in into a q Anon far-right cultist
so I don't know I don't know for sure
wasn't the story that the guy that broke
in was screaming about Nancy like I want
Nancy that to me sounds like I found the
guy's passport and the wreckage on 9 11.
it fell out of the Flaming ball of
airplane and landed on the ground this
proves that he was in the plane you're
like what kind of psycho story is that
passports don't fall out of burning
explosive Rubble like uh and also they
don't prove anything if they did and and
just just having someone tell me that a
guy screamed something political is like
that just sounds like a red hair well
Cass sunstein Obama's disinformations
Czar openly talked about how they need
to spread fake conspiracy theories in
order to make the legitimate conspiracy
theories look bad he also talked about
the importance of infiltrating 911
family members who were victims of the
attacks that happened in New York City
in order to of course send in more
propaganda more disinformation in order
to confuse every everyone and make
everyone look bad who were legitimately
asking questions this is what I'm saying
right it the story can be something
much simpler than people are making it
out to be
it could be that Paul Pelosi was doing
something embarrassing with a local guy
who's a leftist maybe they were friends
something bad happened and they're
trying to cover it up there's two ways
you do it the guy was a cute cultist and
then you get the right to push the most
absurd story possible that no one would
ever believe and here we go I'm seeing
all the memes that are like Paul
Pelosi's gay lover is trending and I'm
like that's how they get you he was
driving the drunk a couple years a year
ago or something and who was the guy who
was with him when he was driving his car
drone oh I don't know was there a guy
with him yeah so so here's my point for
all we know this guy could have been
delivering Drugs That's substantially
more more reasonable and plausible if
you go to a regular person and say do
you think high profile members of the
government do drugs
yes do you think powerful CEOs and
Executives do drugs of course it's like
a movie trout they're doing coke all the
time do you think it's possible that a
drug deal could go bad a small one like
a guy's dropping off at two in the
morning some blow or something that's
that's happened okay so do you think
it's possible this could be something
like that yeah maybe but the guy was
reportedly accused cultist I'm like what
do you think is more plausible that one
of the most secure places in the country
the third in line for the presidency had
no security and a fringe conspiracy
theorist was able to break in and the
government didn't know about it or do
was trying to buy some below and it went
bad right and there to me it's clear the
the social condition that's going on
everything the left does right now is
blamed on you know Maga terrorism white
supremacist terrorism they're trying to
I mean if you any uh you know four-star
general from the military or you know
any corporate CEO you know whatever it
is they're all going to tell you in a
congressional hearing you know the
number one threat to America these days
is Maga terrorism white supremacist
terrorism and again like I think if
there's going to be an explanation for
this you know incident whatever it is
you know that's their go-to card and I
just think they're they're playing that
card every single time because they're
conditioning everyone to to anticipate
that
um you know that eventuality I do
believe the likely scenarios that what
kind of what you were saying Tim that it
that it was like some sort of late night
rendezvous that that got heated or
something like that and they probably
knew each other and and it could be gay
prostitution I just think that is a more
shocking and difficult to believe story
and it's really the worst case scenario
that Paul is doing some blow us some
dude it got out of hand and then he
grabbed the hammer I guess like get out
it's time for you to leave and the guy's
like I'm not leaving Paul we're doing
another line and they were like oh now
there was something about a wellness
check like the cops weren't even called
there originally due to the disturbance
it was a wellness check on Paul as part
of his probation yeah I mean that was in
the original reporting was that they
were they were called there on a
wellness check was that from was that
from when he got caught during driving
is at the yeah at 2 A.M at 2 A.M cool so
hold on no double check me on this
because that was that was the original
the original story I heard was that the
cops were there doing a wellness check
and then that escalated because the
hammer didn't come out like the the in
the original political article they said
that Paul was not attacked with the
hammer until the police arrived it
wasn't it wasn't like they broke up a
hammer attack it's like the police
showed up and then the struggle over the
hammer ensued that was what I heard so
like this I got dispatcher Heather
Grimes had said something was wrong with
the situation an ordered officials to
conduct an expedited wellness check on
the home look at this the glass is
broken it so the glass on both the
outside and the inside people need to
understand it I'm seeing a lot of people
say the glass on the outside you can see
the glasses clearly inside and outside
yeah you could have pulled it out as he
was breaking right right right right so
I I know what Dudu once kicked a glass
window your foot his foot went through
it because it was safety glass and when
he pulled it out he raked it out serious
with his arms and then he just shredded
his arms he's not yank your arms out if
you go through a window stay there and
stay calm yep but anyway glass comes out
the other side too so this is true they
were conducting a wellness so they say
uh quote what's going on let me read
they say Paul Pelosi managed to call
9-1-1 and alert this dispatcher to his
dad situation with without his eventual
attacker even knowing Pelosi the husband
blah blah blah the alleged attacker
David de Papi didn't realize Pelosi had
dialed his phone or understood that
Pelosi was speaking in code what's going
on why are you here what are you going
to do to me Pelosi Pelosi Pelosi Pelosi
allegedly said in order to alert 9-1-1
to the emergency situation see so this
wellness check wasn't random that's what
I thought happened he didn't make a
phone call and say hello there's a man
in my house I don't know him but he's my
friend he was speaking in code the
people don't believe this there were
tons of viral stories that have been
around for a long time of women who
order pizza and they'll say something
they'll call 9-1-1 and say I'd like to
order a large pepperoni pizza ma'am this
is 9-1-1 yes I understand ma'am you're
calling 9-1-1 it's not a pizza place yes
I do understand I would like to order a
large pizza and the dispatcher says are
you in danger ma'am yes and is this
someone threatening him yes and they're
like okay can you tell us what's going
on are you in danger I'm sorry I don't
know and they'll go okay and then the
police show up you like if you've got
some crazy person in front of you and
you download 9-1-1 you can't go help
police Quickie's here because then you
die
or you know I don't know I don't know it
could be anything but I'll tell you this
at the very least
going for the most like circuitous story
Paul Pelosi was having a secret gay
Rendezvous it got out of hand the police
showed up it's like I don't believe that
I also don't believe the political
propaganda you can believe it if you
want I'm just saying tell that to one of
your Normie friends and see how quickly
they dismiss you and think you're insane
yeah stay away from from non-factual
proved proven things right now you gotta
you gotta yeah that's why I'm always
like look sometimes the conspiracies are
true like the DHS store we have right
here we've long had this evidence but if
before these documents were released you
even now it's probably hard you go to
someone and say the government is
colluding with big Tech we've got these
this from this lawsuit people are going
to be like you're crazy now we have the
intercept reporting the leftist
publication it's still going to be hard
because the story sounds so nuts I'm
just saying it may be true you just got
to be careful how you're presenting it
because it sounds ridiculous and it may
be and I recall the Andrew Gillum story
you know that was uh Ron desantis's uh
gubernatorial opponent in 2018 in
Florida and you know there was the story
there where you know he was he was found
you know in a drug-induced coma naked
yeah naked you know having done all
kinds of drugs you know with a gay
escort and you know if those if the
photographic evidence of that Rendezvous
didn't exist that would all be dismissed
as a right-wing conspiracy theory so I
mean that's why it's so important and
then the DHS and the FBI would go to big
Tech social media companies because you
got to send to this right now make sure
no one talks about this if they do they
get kicked off so it's plausible that
right now the media is just trying to
get their story straight that they're
just that's why Politico is like
countries near and Reporting like
they're just trying to get the narrative
right you know they got they say they
got body camera footage near post we'll
say it's it's in kind of police body cam
so release it yeah so where is it but
you know they're gonna they're like well
you know Paul's in his underwear and
I want to hear it more than anything
right
uh okay it's starting to sound a little
less nefarious now that he called the
cops spoken code that's exactly see when
I when I heard the dispatch call and
they said he says he doesn't know him
but he's a friend
you know and he's waiting for his wife
and I saw everybody being like why would
he says he was friends and I'm like it's
like those pizza phone calls where the
woman calls and says like me you know we
want pizza and they're calling 9-1-1 he
called in code
it's believable I I still think there's
something really off about them not
having security doesn't make sense right
and the initial report of a third person
they're saying was just was a
misunderstanding
another person was there come on dude
like we have security and we don't we're
like one a million of the value of the
Pelosi's like seriously you know yeah
for real yeah yeah but likes no sense to
me yeah it was a conscious act by them
to not have security present that raises
a lot of red flags or they had it and
they're they're saying they didn't to
facilitate a story they they just had
the people in they're like don't worry
about it I know the guy and then the
guy's in there right we didn't even have
security it's their budget I I think you
know if I was going to believe in there
there was a conspiracy or anything it'd
probably be that it was a break-in like
the where's Nancy wears Nancy stuff
sounds way too much like the fake AOC
story where is she where is she shut up
that never happened
like I'm sure the cop watch and said
where is she
where is she she's in the bathroom uh
ma'am you need to be evacuated and she's
like they're coming to get me and then
she lied about when it happened to make
it seem like the January 6 rioters were
coming for her when her story took place
a full hour before the capital was even
breached well not in the capital in the
building and then she was not even in
the same building I want to fire off
some healing love to Paul
recover from the uh the head trauma
brother yeah man I hope he's okay like
it's a crazy story regardless I hope
that'll make him run for political
office anytime soon he's had a rough
year I mean just like yeah Baseline is
that a rough year I mean it's you know
self uh self-inflicted rough year Nancy
too It's gotta be stressful like I would
encourage you Nancy like you don't need
to be there I think that a lot of people
that are in Congress they feel like if
they leave they failed but at some point
you got to take care of yourself and
your family and let us take care of the
rest because we're here for you I think
it's like the Bear Bryant situation I
mean he he resisted retiring in Alabama
because he figured if he retired he
would die which he did six months later
like six months after he retired from
coaching football he was dead I think a
lot of these members of Congress they're
so Old Nation they don't want to die and
they they figure that hey if I go retire
then that'll be it'll be in the great
because purpose keeps you alive yeah
sure that's right and work too people
who retire I think retirement age is
like the highest most likely time of
death absolutely they could keep working
if they retire from Congress yeah we
shouldn't put humans in a position where
they're 85 and feel like they can't stop
being a
and their entire self-esteem and
self-worth is wrapped up in that office
yeah totally all right I hope you guys
are ready for some more bad news the
stories from Politico Biden bashes oil
sector for war profiteering and warns of
windfall tax on profits you know what
that means right
if they put a tax on the profits for gas
companies what do you think is going to
happen the price of gas is going to go
up yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna punish them for
price gouging All of You by charging
them more money so they'll have to be
forced to increase the prices is that
what you're saying yeah people people
you know need to understand gas is
higher in some places than other places
because of the gas tax of the government
already taxing it the government could
make gas lower by just not taxing it but
now they're deciding we're just gonna
tax it even more which is absolutely
ridiculous I've heard that oil companies
have been maintaining record profits uh
oil companies get record profits amid
Global crisis what is it what does that
mean record profit 55 billion this last
quarter between and what's epx on
Chevrolet what about an apple no no no
no hold on hold on 55 billion in profit
yeah okay I'm not I'm not a fan if
they're ranking in the profits at a time
of Crisis but hold on what was their
total revenue
uh what was what was the gross revenue
uh to profit and then last year and the
year before I wanna I wanna know their
total profit to total gross revenue you
know why because of inflation yeah right
so they could say it's a record profit
yeah because inflation is up 10 so they
got 5 billion more than they got last
year does that mean the buying power of
their profit is the exact same but the
number is larger because Biden's because
of bite inflation this uh from the
guardian shows that Exxon made second
quarter profits 17.8 billion four times
the year before so their their second
quarter profits were four times uh in
one year we did not have four times
inflation I have a feeling that these
companies are spiking the deal that
they're taking advantage of it for sure
because I see Biden begging them to
lower their prices on Twitter and
they're just like we don't have to but
um but it's not just these companies
it's also Saudi Arabia it's also Russia
it's also a lot of other you know
countries that produce oil
plus Biden shut down Keystone and banned
fracking on certain lands so if he
really wanted to get things down he
could be increasing competition and he's
not absolutely yeah if you really want
to harm the energy companies increase
the domestic oil supply and that's you
know increased exploration that's
produced regulations if you want to make
them have fewer profits then you know
increase competition exactly because if
you add tax to the gas company taxes and
you can't make them set their price I
mean can you legally in the United
States make a company set its price
price that's very communist you could do
that in Venezuela because it's a
communist so that's that's referred to
as price fixing it wouldn't be legal
that's what they did to toilet paper in
Venezuela yeah and that man you can't
get toilet paper I don't know a whole
lot about Brazil's politics but seeing
you know Lula win made me kind of
worried because it is a lot of I don't
know man I don't know enough about
politics to say too much it probably
would not be fair for me to comment but
bolsonaro's out he's out and I look at
stuff like this and I'm like people were
all like Trump is bad and then they vote
for Biden but it's like I'm gonna make
your gas cost 10 times as much and here
you go right well Lula is another world
economic Forum member so there you go
I'm sure Brazil is going to be uh you
know protecting the globalist policies
uh that of course are pushing the UN 20
30 Vision so Russia is all let me sell
you our gas through the Mediterranean
United States the United States it's all
nah
nah can't nah don't don't compute nah
and Russia's like yo let's be trade
partners and they're like
is this still people are afraid of
Communism like they're afraid and but
Russia is Russia's not communist it's a
federation and there and the U.S seems
to be buddy buddy with China at least in
a lot of regards I should I should say
Democrats like Biden are which is fine I
want to be trade partners with China and
Russia I think the three countries can
run the world together you know and then
we'll spread American republicanism
ideally they but they disagree with you
the Chinese Communist party is is
worried about American republicanism so
they want to crush it
so what do you do I saw a video out of
Brazil
um you know it could have been fake but
I think it was it was really there were
multiple videos I think I know what
you're talking about yeah it was
um a recording of a major prison in
Brazil of the prisoners celebrating as
they received the news that this you
know Lula whatever his name is uh
defeated bolsonaro because they know
that this guy is a left-wing radical
he's a jailbreak Justice type of guy
yeah and they know that their sentences
are about to become a lot lighter yeah
there's allegedly a lot of gang members
um in the favelas shooting off guns and
celebrating as well allegedly that's not
a good sign and he was charged with he
was he was convicted of corruption or
something it was like stealing millions
of dollars
amazing but look man that's par for the
course down there to be honest but not
just that I mean even the United States
you have people who will vote for John
fetterman right his brain is is busted
and I feel bad for the guy man but he's
not all there and they're people who
vote for him the same thing is true of
Joe Biden there are people who hate you
so much they would vote for a ham
sandwich if it and you suffered that's a
great point and it also shows the left
they view their political leaders as
just merely vessels for their ideology
you know that you know Joe bid I mean
Joe Biden is the commander-in-chief and
everyone can see plain as day that he is
mentally incapacitated doesn't matter
he's just he's a vehicle John fetterman
I mean he could be the ideal U.S senator
for the left he's just you know he's an
empty vessel he can he can you know
he'll vote yay or nay the way they want
to every single time that's perfect for
him and that's just that's I think
that's that's a hard pill for a minute
to swallow is that that's that's where
we are as a country it's where our
political system is we have one party
that in this cycle could potentially
elect someone who is you know a walking
Bears report
yep man that's brutal fetterman meant
you know he he and we can't talk about
why he's in this condition can we well
we should because he lived across the
street from a steel mill but we can talk
about it on the after show if you want
to really get into it fair enough but he
had a stroke in May and now the timing
of that was interesting and and he's
unable to effectively communicate and
they argue that it's just his auditory
processes but I he clearly can't speak
and they lied about that dude I watched
an interview in his house it's echoing
booming echoes in his house because this
is wide open they have wooden floors
it's just constant sound just nailing
him he went that sound messed that guy
up he took he took the steel mill from
across the street breathing in all that
carbon oh man John well people in this
country are willing to vote for as you
said empty vessels but I but I think
it's it's not just that they're going to
vote yay or nay as they want it it's
that they will they they hold in their
hearts the same level of hatred for you
Joe Biden going out on TV and saying the
Maga Republicans are an extremist threat
he hates you as much as all of his
voters do it's like their only policy is
we hate you and we want you to suffer
that's it now they'll argue that's what
Republicans think and there's probably a
lot of Republicans that are you know
probably doing that way I don't know I
think the Republicans are fairly bad in
a lot of ways but you sit down here and
we talk with some of these various uh
politicians and they will articulate
their positions about why they want to
do what they're doing and then you you
take a look at the Modern Democrat
narrative and its modern Republicans are
evil right it's like well when we talk
about like child sex changes we have
very real real concerns we can easily
articulate what's wrong with it they'll
just say but you're a racist you're a
bigot you you you're transphobic like
not even give you an argument they just
don't like you exactly and and we on the
right are so unprepared to deal with
that ideology they're not interested in
debate we we wrap ourselves we I think
we we kind of make a uh a lower G God
out of our intellect out of our ability
to rationalize whereas the the
opposition they don't care about that no
all they care about is crushing you yeah
and you know they don't care like that's
the whole Ben Shapiro thing like Ben
Shapiro you know will will Dazzle you
with his intellect but when you're when
you look like like their feelings don't
care about your facts so so how are you
prepared to defeat that more importantly
Ben Shapiro actively tries to have
conversations with people he disagrees
with and come to an understanding and I
respect that but they don't care right
they don't care they're going to vote
for John German well so
I think the best example is we will
invite them to sit down here and express
themselves and they will say no
every single libertarian traditional
disaffected liberal and conservative
will say anytime let me know when but
the Democrat left is nope no dice and
even even when I talk to them on the
street they'll be like uh delete that
delete that recording you can't use it
it's like bro you're in public you
walked into my camera that's not how it
works we've had we've had a couple so it
happened to me I felt that story but
we've actually had some instances for
timcast.com where people are like I've
changed my mind and it's like dude you
said in public in front of everyone what
you said like we you walk up to us we're
filming it you can't come later but I
revoke consent to being filmed I'm not
sure if you guys saw it was Matt Walsh
he was doing a speech and he this young
trans it was a man I I don't know what
gender the person was but they were
trans and they were they were talking to
Matt and like I don't know what to do
you say these things I'm upset and I
don't want to put words in their mouths
you should watch the interview it's
great and then Matt was like I don't
just I don't hate you I love I I want
the best for you I'm angry with these
pharmaceutical companies selling
medicines for profit that haven't been
tested and telling people that they're
that they're safe this is the test run I
care deeply you could see like he really
cares about these people yes that was an
example of someone from the left
expressing their emotions and someone
from the right understanding and
communicating in their language you know
an emotional way yeah all but also
displaying some facts about the
pharmaceutical companies and sure and I
saw that was very powerful and you know
it's a great example of you know the the
the you can't have and ultimately you
know quote free market because that's a
great example is these you know quote
gender transition uh you know genital
mutilation treatments I said treatment
they're just barbaric procedures in
Arkansas you know we we had a state law
that was passed that would have outlawed
them for minors uh our Republican
Governor vetoed that legislation we
overroduced that's there's there's
that's the rub you know he is a you know
Republican governor of a deep red State
an R plus 30 State this is Arkansas and
the Republican Governor vetoed the
legislation and um you know that that
law got passed it was overridden that we
we overwrote his veto in the legislature
but that law there was a big lawsuit
which is still ongoing and you know the
plaintiffs in that lawsuit trying to
stop the law from being implemented it
was you know all the uh you know medical
associations the University of Arkansas
for medical Sciences Walmart the Walmart
Foundation
um the Arkansas Chamber of Commerce you
know like all these big you know
entities
um you know I would just like the the
globalist for lack of a better term you
know they're against it and so you can't
say that word anymore now remember who
said that so there was this actually is
uh uh I don't want to derail you though
if you want to finish your thoughts no
no that was really we're we're we're
powerless right now to stop that from
happening even in deep red States and
that's that's hard for us to swallow
they started this campaign that actually
started I think in like 2018 against
Alex Jones that globalist is
anti-Semitic and then people are like
but what do I say to describe someone
who wants a one world government and
they're like you can't
it's anti-semitis like what are you
saying about Jewish people I say
internationalists there's nationalists
and there's internationalists
internationalists care more for
international relations and community
and nationalists care more for their
nation and Country
name calling in general is looked down
upon don't call don't slander
it's not name calling yeah it's not name
calling it's a description of an
ideology I think globalist is a good
time I just use Google but name-calling
people is like yeah let's let's let's
talk culture War we have this from the
New York Post Twitter to start charging
20 per month for verification under new
owner Elon Musk are you gonna pay Tim
yes oh Meister money bags tell me more
I've talked about this a lot before I
think that uh verification should be
literally for the purpose of verifying
users so you know who I am so there's no
impersonators so that I can be like this
is my official account then Tim cast
news will also buy its verification say
this is the official account of Tim cast
news so that you don't follow the wrong
account and it's easily there for you
and the other thing people don't realize
is it's going to come with features and
I think I I just think it's ultimately
good that regular people can choose to
sign up and then you know you're talking
to a real person makes the platform way
more valuable in my opinion yeah you
want to per you know put your money
where your mouth is and and right now
Elon Musk and Twitter are promising some
some really amazing things to combat a
lot of the nonsense that we're facing if
if they Backtrack on it if the
government defeats them if they don't if
if Elon doesn't keep his promise I'm
canceling my 20 subscription that's
another way to vote with your dollar
um and and he also talked about uh you
know there's also rumors right now that
he might bring back Vines soon he
tweeted about that he's going to a lot
of cryptocurrency on the platform and
allow people to of course uh have
end-to-end encryption so he's promising
a lot of good things that that I think
are interesting so far he's he's doing
things that that I I think are good I I
I I I I can't really criticize him he
hasn't done everything I wanted him to
do but it's still early but I'm going to
be keeping an eye on here's the best
part
many of the woke Twitter Roddy these
journalists they don't have 10 000
followers five thousand twenty thousand
but they're verified meanwhile they were
people like James O'Keefe they banned
him and he had like a million something
and he was not verified Julian Assange
not verified for these people it's the
only thing that makes them feel valuable
or important and Elon is gonna rip it
right out of their chests and I want to
see it there are people that they're
like well you know I have a verified
Twitter account with 5 000 followers and
I'm like oh yeah buddy so does my dog my
dog's verified these people build their
self-worth off of getting verified on
Twitter working for these big
institutions and being prestigious and
Elon Musk is going to kaliman rip it
right out from him and then I'm gonna
laugh the whole time because they stake
their value in a little stupid icon on a
social media platform ah thanks Elon I
went the other direction I am not
verified I have no interesting but I
will only become verified if they ask me
to become verified that's my goal with
Twitter well again you're a free person
you could do whatever you want and it's
going to be interesting because this is
a way to to fight against the pressure
that Elon Musk is facing from Bill Gates
The Washington Post and a lot of people
in The Establishment that are calling
for an Advertiser boycott now with this
new system yeah boycott all you want we
don't care we got people paying for for
the platform if they want to use it I'm
going to be paying for it I want to use
it especially if he keeps his promises
he does it I'm gonna boycott it that was
my plan up until Elon bought it was I'm
never going to ask to be verified if
they come to me and they're like okay
hey come give verified Ian I would do it
now this sounds like an upgrade of
Twitter blue so this is just basically
the paid version of Twitter I kind of
like it because if it offers a bunch of
cool features like editing longer tweets
things like that longer videos it might
be just be worth paying the 20 bucks for
in that case I would maybe consider
doing it and if it comes with
verification then there's talk of longer
videos right um I do think though you
know I guess inversely Twitter needs to
be paying its top accounts for producing
content or just do some ad share or you
know yeah just share some of that money
you could pay some percentage of the
Twitter blue income well or yeah right
but based on like how many views do your
tweets get or something like that it's
always tough because then people will
make inflammatory tweets maybe put
legitimate fake news for the purpose of
generating traffic
but that's YouTube right right so what
do you do oh yeah
yeah so would you police it or would you
just have you know just kind of a true
like referral you allow the advertisers
to advertise on who or what they want to
do if they're offended by someone you
just simply give them the choice like
okay I won't
your your content won't be shown with
this person's content he also Elon also
talked about having a platform where you
decide your experience so you could go
into a kid's version of of Twitter where
of course everyone cares about your
emotions everyone is there calling you
by your pronoun and your gender and then
an adult version where people could
actually have you know rational real
conversations that don't need to play by
certain rules a wild west and when you
do that you open kind of the pathway of
individuals to kind of determine their
own experience which I think is awesome
and great you could gamify the system I
built uh and then you can't say you
can't have a person complain like I I
can't I don't want to go on the kids
playground then if you don't want to be
in the adult section go and go into the
little playground pit here on online I
built a gamification model for mines
where you would be basically get tokens
for using the site you could use these
tokens to buy or to hire avatars that
you'll send out on missions and then
every day you'll get a notification
throughout the day if you click the
notification it's like your hero found a
sword if you're there if you don't click
the notification he doesn't find it so
you'll be like it'll create generate
attention for the site and then when
they come back from their mission you
get a trophy that goes in your profile
so if you want to turn on gamification
mode is there a play and then that'd be
a good way to integrate utility tokens
well let me just invert invert that on
you is there a DND social media but you
can totally do that you could battle
against friends and use tokens to
empower abilities I would like like like
it's it's basically a social media
website but it's a DND game and then
dude you could augment react do
augmented DND Twitter like you could
look at your friend and like have a
turn-based at game it'd be so fun I'd
I'd probably sign up for something like
that it'd be wild and you could it could
be an overlay where you flip it on and
then just turn it back off if you don't
want it on or not I'm just saying like
literally I bet someone's gonna comment
saying it exists but I'm saying like oh
website where you create a profile you
friend people and your profile is also a
level leveling up character with
notifications that like you can engage
in scenarios and play games yeah that'd
be fun hell yeah that'd be a fun game
like
it's there's got to be something like
that I don't know the model's built so
if you want to implement it Elon let me
know we just didn't have enough
developers at mines to put it up it's
like a it's like a social media MMO yeah
you know yeah it's a good token sync
because the thing about utility tokens
and giving them out is you're making
them you need a way to to deflate the
currency so it's a good way for people
to put tokens back into the system right
kids version yeah what is it oh Russell
Brand gave your I word tweet props
yesterday on his YouTube segment
I just started tweeting words like none
of those broke the rules I was like I
said can I tweet naughty words now when
Elon bought would finally close the deal
as I started tweeting words that
are questionable I guess for Twitter's
rules or something but it's like you can
basically tweet most words without
actually getting in trouble on YouTube I
mean I mean on Twitter
that's how most these platforms work
anyway have you seen more engagement in
the past week or so well I gained a
bunch of followers yeah I guess people
are trying to see this bike too I did as
well yep yeah without tweeting very much
so yep yeah I just think
what happened with Twitter is that when
they realized journalists were using it
that was their that was their core user
base and started pandering to them is
their Echo chamber and that's how
stories are generated the reason so
Twitter talked about removing follower
counts retweet counts and uh and making
verification for everybody and they just
decided never not to do it and the
reason because the journalists liked the
gamified retweet counts like bragging
about their follow accounts and they
like the fact the verification badge is
a status symbol that's granted to you
like Knighthood so they would never give
up on it I think if Elon Musk strips all
that away here's what I say Elon should
remove follower counts remove retweet
counts put all those analytics behind
the scenes you can find someone's
profile you don't know how many
followers they have you can follow them
if you want you can see how many
followers you have the public doesn't
see it you tweet something out they can
retweet it if they want no one can see
how many retweets it has why why is the
retweet icon got a number on it
what's the point of that it's free the
user can use that number to inflate
their own value if they want to give you
can see it behind the scenes why is it
being shown you're right you could yeah
you don't need to be public it's not
like I saw your Tweet and need to know
that it was also a part of you know 10
000 other accounts broadcast that makes
no sense it's a it's a it's a value
symbol sure the same thing with ratios
Twitter intentionally built the system
for the quote unquote ratio there's no
reason to show me a number of replies
right well and just show me the replies
unless you want drama unless you want to
see who got ratioed unless you want to
start controversy and and I think these
organizations have been doing that
deliberately they have been pushing I
think a divide and conquer agenda that
makes people hate each other and fight
each other based on trivial differences
that don't really matter in our lives
and I think at the end of the day it
wasn't an accident I think the FBI DHS
is like hey we got to make sure that
these people fight each other so they
don't really see what's really happening
to them and that's a perfect way of
doing that and now we have the proof the
government has been controlling the big
Tech social media companies so it's fair
to assert right now that they are the
ones pushing for ratios pushing for
hatred pushing for all the divisiveness
and all the drama that of course
captivates big Tech social media I just
hope you launched ready for the storm I
mean it's just beginning I mean they're
they're not going to let him just you
know purchase a piece of the cathedral
as you said the other day I mean that's
he he's got a piece of it now and
they're not they're not just going to
let that go quietly you can't hold it
it's like the one ring Elon need to
disperse it melt it into dust Elon knows
who Michael malice is he needs to call
up Michael and say let's talk Michael
needs to give start advising him on how
to deal with a lot of the stuff yes
decentralize the algorithm you want all
this stuff out of your own hands healing
you don't want to hold people's
passwords you don't want to hold
people's
names and addresses and and stuff like
that getting email email verification
keep it as as Baseline as possible and
get that stuff out uh like uh well I'll
go into more detail later I think he's
going to try and turn it into x.com
right he made X Holdings right to
acquire it into PayPal he right he wants
to make it the one app for everything
like WeChat the American WeChat and
that's that's kind of scary if you think
about it it's I don't look there's a lot
of good things coming from Elon but I
don't I don't completely trust him he's
got business dealings in China
is this necessarily going to be a good
thing if we if if we end up using
Twitter think about how bad twitter is
with censorship and we're hoping Elon
fixes it it's still bad Viva fry got
suspended for tweeting about the Paul
Pelosi thing which is BS yeah imagine
you start using that for your payment
processing and for everything
and the censorship never gets fixed so
I'm not entirely confident it's like
he's in a position like George
Washington was After the Revolution
where he's the now he's the president
and they want him to become king people
will be like hey
just you be the one in charge don't do
it dude you got to give up the power
he's got a part in the political
prisoners he has to unban a lot of these
people but how is he going to deal with
the Department of Homeland Security
breathing down his neck being like no
you're not when so much of his
businesses are dependent on government
contracts
yep so SpaceX especially yeah this is
you know they're going to come after
them they're going to punish them sure
all the satellites that they're building
you know sure all the tech that they're
building his kind of dalliance with
transhumanism is is concerning as well
you know neuralink and you know his
business in China it's it's it's it's
it's not a you know it's not a good guy
be skeptical of everyone obviously but
when it comes to the Battle of ideas he
is he is proposing Amazing Ideas
important ideas that no one else is and
they're crucially important for our uh
existence right now I agree so his
battles against Bill Gates his battles
against depopulation his battles against
you know the the real things that are
coming and are going to be hurting
Humanity I think are important and you
know I'm still not 100 convinced I'm
still skeptical of them but I think so
far he's one of the best things we have
right now when it comes to ensuring
freedom of speech no a human has that
can handle that responsibility though
you need to disperse the wrong robot
you're right it should be an automated
system like like a Department of
Homeland Security right like a big
federal government that knows you know
government bureaucrats sitting in
offices deciding what people you know
can and cannot do right no no no a
system where everybody holds their own
private keys and can log in with their
own private data and log out and no
there's no Central
um repository of data that the DHS can
go after you just say because I can't
give you the info because I don't have
it I never did that's the point if you
have it they will come and take it we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you at
about 11 p.m let's read what we got here
it's me says visit Pelosi Vineyards a
smashing good time I like how the memes
are like Pelosi hammered everything
hammered and like Nancy Pelosi's always
hammered or whatever yeah and I'm like I
don't know if that's too soon you know I
hope the guy's okay man you need to get
brain surgery I hope he's all right yeah
that's brutal
Let's see we got
cabarrojo says Tim and crew Shameless
plug for both of us single grain of sand
just released our next song Oracle
exclusively on Rumble all about MSM
corruption Mass formation hypnosis
looking forward to your next song on
11-4 music Saves the World ah yes
earlier in the show I received uh top
secret documents
for the new song release for the music
video we're putting out which is going
to ruffle feathers I'm really excited
for it who's that super chatter just now
something Sheamus something Rojo oh I
just think of Sheamus why'd you think it
was Jake I don't know you you remind me
of a taller more muscular version of my
friend Sheamus
good looking guy yeah yeah the potato
man yes Luke loves potato man
Raymond g Stanley Jr says holy mix of
emotions Tim jubilant for the story
angry at the government weary the cult
will stay the cult and worried someone
will do something stupid so the media
can brush the story onto the rug I mean
this Pelosi guy is a crazy guy did
something stupid you know they can say
what the story is anyway so Christina H
says scary news on Halloween how
appropriate that's right it is Halloween
and it rained today too it always rains
on Halloween really bleak yep
crispy Joe says with all the craziness
going on bring the man Alex Jones back
on the show okay Alex come on the show
it's always a good show with Alex Jones
we have a skit when it comes to our Alex
Jones's right jar yeah
yeah it'd be super cool
all right
salty duckling says what are your
thoughts on the Chris Rose arrest in
Florida he was protesting an illegal
two-way infringement by the DeSantis
campaign with Goa Florida director Louis
Valdez DeSantis is slowly showing how
much of a neocon tyrant he truly is
Benedict Arnold 2. I don't know anything
about it what happened you know Luke I
haven't heard anything in this story I'm
going to look into it now but thank you
for letting us know Christopher Rose was
the guy's name Chris Rose
all right Dominic camarada says hey Tim
my brother doesn't believe the left
doesn't run every institution can you
please do a clip-worthy response as how
they do
it's not really the kind of content I
make you know I do opinion and
commentary and news analysis so doing
like a deep dive documentary on the left
control of Institutions isn't something
I would do I don't know who would be a
good person for that
are you asking me I don't anybody okay
any recommendations no idea
no idea
all right let's see Trey hudspeth says
Luke where the huhas it doesn't matter
if you talk about Civil War I'm drinking
tonight it's Halloween
who has her with everyone you know
William Nichols says I stumbled on
Taylor Lorenz doing a live stream on
Tick Tock tonight I said who is his old
broad and she blocked me
oh you know there you go
Ola says happy Halloween Tim and crew
watched quote kill all others episode
last night honestly you hyped it too
much it wound up being more about the
aliens than anything else the conclusion
underwhelming I don't know I thought it
was still great I don't know what you
mean some of those black mirrors are all
over the place well this is this is
electric dreams oh yeah
yeah I thought it was crazy I thought it
was good
all right all right where are we at D
stuff says Arkansas resident here
excited to see Jake on the show voted
for him in the primaries to get rid of
the Rhino Bozeman hope to be able hope
to be able to vote for him again in the
future good luck Jake
absolutely what was that like running
yeah Go hogs it was a it was a battle I
mean it was my first campaign obviously
uh jumped off the high dive taking on an
incumbent U.S senator
um it's it's hard to take on incumbents
these days you know the establishment is
so powerful they I mean it was the most
expensive Primary in Arkansas political
history
um Bozeman spent about 12 million
against me I raised 12 billion three
yeah between him and his past and I mean
it was it was really funny I mean I'm
sure this this what was the commenter's
name I'm sure he's tough yeah I'm sure
he he saw the the tv ads the since I was
a new candidate you know low Name ID
their strategy was to paint me as a
democrat in Disguise I don't know me
that well but that's one thing I'm not
and so they just they ran these ads with
my face in between Nancy Pelosi and AOC
as fake Jake you know the the liberal
who's going to defeat Donald Trump's
America First agenda but that's how
politics works I mean they just took an
undefined candidate and with their War
chest that's how they defined me and
that created enough doubt in people's
mind that you know we fell short of
forcing their runoff wow you know it was
a I mean it was a great learning
experience you know it was you know
hopefully a first step and we'll see
what happens would you do anything
different if you were going to do it
again
I I'm not sure that defeating an
incumbent is possible in the Senate
anymore
um you know I I wouldn't change a thing
in terms of the campaign I mean I I took
bull positions you know I think that I
moved the needle
um you know Force Bozeman to to take
some tough votes in the Senate that he
did not want to do he voted against the
first 40 billion dollars of Ukraine Aid
when he's been an establishment student
his entire career but right before the
primary was that first vote and he voted
and he voted no I was very proud of that
I mean he only did that I mean there
were like four or five other Senators I
mean and Bozeman was not part of that
crew
um so you know the only thing that I
would possibly reevaluate is taking on
an incumbent I salute those who do but
you know unless you have a dead body in
your trunk in your incumbent you're
going to win re-election it's just it's
they have too much money they're too
powerful and you know it's it's tough
all right baseman 619 says
Paul had just finished his third glass
of wine when the door rang he's here
Paul excitedly spritzed a bit of Nancy's
Obsession onto his neck as he licked his
lips and grabbed the hammer as he headed
to the door
too soon
sounds like he was there yeah that was
worth the 30 dollars thanks basement we
have the best commenters I'm in the chat
the whole show reading almost all of
them you guys are incredible check those
off
kalishnikov says the reason the right
doesn't protest isn't cultural it's
systematic oppression social media
repeatedly censors right-wing Gatherings
along with the barrage of media smears
and Military adversity
yeah I think that the definition like
protests have changed to online now if
you make a internet Youtube channel and
you get 100 000 views that's a big Pro
like you're able to protest things with
your voice and then people will listen
and change and you don't have to stress
out the militants by gathering tons of
people because that's when they start to
get really concerned is when there's
large groups
Jason Takes says on the Joe Rogan show
vijaya's smug answer to you about the
government being comfortable about
Twitter's actions make a lot more sense
now
that's right yeah interesting that's
true Tina Collette says try to share
this live feed to my Facebook page it
kept trying to share your will of the
people music video instead that's a
weird uh YouTube glitch where it shows
the graphic from it instead I think so
maybe it was working but it was showing
the wrong graphic
I don't know you'll all many people also
noticed that when we launch the live
streams there's no thumbnails often it's
just like a gray block
what's up with that
who knows yeah
but then when people are scrolling
through YouTube they see a gray block
and they don't realize it's the show and
then they don't you know they ignore it
or people are like I can't find it how
do I find it and it's like it's the gray
block because they're not putting our
thumbnail up very weird huh how about
that I got a notification today which is
good but that's I mean that's the first
one in a couple weeks so Perry LC says
USA out of diesel coming November 21st
2022. oh I'm excited for that well we're
down to 21 days someone want to Google
US diesel Supply just to make sure
because I know we were at 25 days but
they replenish it it's not like it just
goes down in 25 days and then just
disappears sure it's if if Supply
stopped there would be 25 days until
it's gone yeah that's still absolutely
insane it's the worst diesel stops
everything stops especially farming like
that is super dangerous people don't
understand it's not just gasoline
feeling this country it's diesel I think
this members only segment is going to be
particularly lit because I've been
watching a bunch of stuff over the
weekend plus some of the stuff we were
talking about so sign up at timcast.com
for the members show yeah did you did
you look it up yeah I'm reading about it
what does it say how much is left 21 25.
26 million
barrels they usually have a number they
have a chart there's a chart that shows
how many days in a supplier left okay
this might take me some time well see if
you can find it let's read some more
Jon Stewart says ten dollars more for
the Alex Jones was right jar we actually
have a lot of money in that jar yeah
yeah but but like I I don't know why
people just put money in it you know
like whether or not they're listening to
Alex Jones they put money in it
oh let's grab some more Super chats
Michael McLeod says can we impeach Biden
now Harris be damned the regime has got
to go uh when the Republicans win maybe
you'll get some support some for
impeachment I doubt half the Republicans
would sign on for it though half would
be four half would be against it
I'm from News Talk
kgvo.com yeah 25 days of supply of
diesel Supply you're asking for
something specific about a change in
that well anyway it looks like we're
about 25 days 25 yeah that's where we've
been here
Douglas Caplan with a very big Super
Chat thank you very much as Tim I have
to ask this earlier today I got a
message claiming to be you I have to
know was that really you posting to me
in that one YouTube message you talk on
telegram I said about Luke talking about
the dust from Bill Gates thing and I
made a reference to Bible Revelation and
the sun shining through a sky like
like sad cloth
if anybody is messaging you claiming to
be me it's a scambot that's just it to
scambot there's like scambots that post
crypto scams with my avatar on on
YouTube and stuff yeah everywhere it's
crazy they don't crack down on those but
but you you dare talk about some
vitamins
it's the end of you if the account isn't
verified
man look all my all my YouTube accounts
are verified and my Twitter's verify my
Instagram's verified that's the point of
verification so
safety and happiness says salty tears
Tsunami alert well okay
I'm listening Leif Hagin says why did
Hillary let Benghazi happen then blame
it on an even jailed guy for posting a
film online why did Pelosi let January 6
happen then use it as an excuse to
silence Trump and remove parlor
no good questions cultural abduction
says Timmy do you think the Twitter
story is the biggest October surprise
ever
yeah I mean look we've got hard
confirmation the US government is
colluding to manipulate and manufacture
public opinion that is massive like I
that is in that is insane it's huge it's
like real deep State yeah I mean there
you go they're like Dave's it doesn't
exist you're gonna be like here's a
story from The Intercept a progressive
left-leaning publication yeah
and it's this lawsuit from Missouri it's
a really interesting man
all right a pan and Nicolas is basically
Tim my gripe with electric dreams
episode is that you made it sound like a
Twilight Zone Thriller but it wasn't
nearly as interesting ah I think so
maybe you shouldn't like it that's fine
you're not you know we don't like the
same things it is what it is I think
people should watch it do you guys watch
it yet Luke nope I have no what are you
doing huh you guys haven't watched it
yeah for shame I like to make it you got
to watch electric dreams on Amazon Prime
the episode is called kill all others
okay yes interesting show
all right all right none of your
business says Ian lava bits SSL keys
were used for transport encryption not
message encryption they could still be
used to decrypt incoming mail without
pgp interesting some of those words went
over my head but that does explain that
it wasn't direct messaging to messaging
SSL Keys thank you
Patriot American says Jake the right is
split into four factions one the old
right two paleocons three neocons and
four the new right and the Libertarians
we need to bring all the
anti-establishment supporters from all
factions together if we're going to win
this
I think we need International Community
Support as well it does not stop at the
end of the American Border we need
everybody on board what do you mean by
that like we need Global support just
like the Americans couldn't win the
revolution without the French we can't
do this without the world's support we
need all of these all the
anti-establishment force from all these
other countries to come together to form
a coalition to compete against those who
are trying to form this International
Coalition you know what I'm saying right
you know what I mean like in a parallel
economy is that what you're saying yeah
multiple parallel economies I think that
there's this mindset with us you're
against us kind of mindset that's not
true you can be parallel of you without
being with or for
or against
let's grab more Super chats Ian Kenny
says Obama through the ndaa got rid of
the Smith Mund Act of 1948 and Foreign
Relations authorization Act of 1987
which prevented the US government from
using propaganda on the American public
wow yeah people talk about that quite a
bit
no
Triton 54 says it's here the
establishment is so desperate it's
telling on itself never before have they
been as dangerous as they are right now
keep an eye out for our 911 size
distraction Trump's arrest mushroom
clouds ears and eyes open
desperation is a is it is it what's the
word
pungent perfume right I like that yeah
pungent
salt Miner says hey Tim so glad you
brought Jake on I'm a huge hog fan and
just wanted to say I love watching you
play we are in dark times and we are
going to need more people like all of
you in the coming days thank you
Razorback fans are the best and we
didn't talk about the NFL much but what
was the greatest play of your life
greatest play so it probably happened in
college yeah you got your Super Bowl
ring a Super Bowl ring for those who
haven't seen this very subtle piece of
jewelry here
that's why I never wear it but it was
great for the campaign you seen that
thing yeah this is cool yeah
yeah when I was in college probably my
the play I'm best known for my senior
year against South Carolina
um came on The Blind Side sack and like
literally knocked the quarterback
unconscious he fumbled the ball scored
the next play kind of ended the game so
wow yeah that was uh I let off my
campaign launch video with that with
that hit just to kind of set the time
do that in the U.S Senate there you go
cool yeah Super Bowl ring yeah Rob says
I sold all my Bitcoin and bought Doge a
month ago so far have doubled my money
wow just been not Financial advice what
was that what was the Catalyst I mean
Elon I think yeah okay Elon support Elon
might integrate it with Twitter is he
really he might that's because you don't
know you never know 116 in the last week
I have 46 Doge I just cannot take it
seriously it's not based on anything
it's just it's just a well I mean you
can make it your utility token you can
look it up so there was some Goldman
Trader who literally retired off of Doge
speculation like he saw what was coming
and he put like you know a couple
million to Doge at like one penny and
then sold it at maybe a dollar or
whatever like maybe 60 whatever at the
peak he sold out at the peak and made
you know nine figures wow I think it was
like 14 cents at one point it's uh what
is it right now 1.2 cents yeah I think
it was up to I don't know yeah last week
it was seven cents now it's 12. yeah I
think it hit in the mid 60s yeah
right now it's a 12. that was the peak
yeah yeah and you know what's funny is
like you'd think that because we're in
the news we would be really good at
these trades because like we're sitting
here going like oh look you know Elon
there's rumors of him integrating Doge
and now Doge's his you know value is
spiking and then we just don't do
anything we don't buy any dojo and then
a week goes by and they're like oh yeah
I doubled my money on Doge and it's like
how are we the ones doing the show and
not capitalizing some crazy dudes put
like all their money into that kind of
thing that that gamble the highest it's
ever been is 63 cents right that was a
year and a half ago that's crazy wow it
went from like
it went from nine thousandth of a cent
to 60 cents how many Deutscher created
each year that's the question a lot yeah
it's like two percent I think there's
132 billion in Supply right now and the
maximum Supply oh it's is it at its
maximum there is no Max it's supposed to
print it infinitely it's supposed to be
inflationary currency yeah it's not
there's no value to it like the values
the idea you want it to be the idea of
it was that the money supply would
expand whereas with the other cryptos
like well like Bitcoin it's eventually
going to stop right the idea with doge
is that it can be used as cash because
it just goes up two percent every year
something it's a meme coin yeah
literally yeah I mean I bought like it
could work 100 bucks when I first came
out like 2013 and then that computer got
stolen in my car imagine my shock when
it was 67 cents and I couldn't cash out
on that I'm watching the price change in
real time as we're talking about oh wow
Harrison Bonner says Luke fellow New
Hampshire and freedom lover here but
currently stuck behind the Iron Curtain
in MA oh no thanks for all that you and
the crew at timcast do would love to buy
you a beer someday or if we're lucky
another Louie oh man
though he was fun we catch up in some
Louis 13 when the Elon closed the deal
oh wow yeah very expensive I had that
one time at the uh the Patriots rookie
dinner that was a highlight every season
uh in the NFL some teams stopped doing
it the Patriots still did it because
Brady was very into it
um every year one road trip the veterans
would make all like take all the rookies
out to dinner and give us the tab
and I think it was like thirty four
thousand dollars wow and so yeah we had
all the cognac all the bottles of wine I
mean and the rookies had to pay for it
and the rookies
and we divided it up based on signing
bonus so I was a third round pick so my
I think my my cut was like two grand wow
we had two first-run picks I think
theirs was like you know ten or twelve
thousand dollars
for one dinner but yeah the tab was like
thirty four thousand dollars wow is that
including tip that's including for the
entire team for the entire team well
yeah most of the team went out and uh
you know Brady I mean just this guy's
worth you know nine figures and he was
he was the ringleader he was like you
know ordering everything and just me he
loved like sticking up to the young guys
did he get it stuck to him I'm sure this
was like PTSD from like his rookie
dinner nine figure salary and you're
gonna make the the low guy pay for it
I'm too much of a of a commie to allow
something like that it's commitment well
they're making so much money like I mean
imagine is that the purpose it's like
exactly it's just kind of a it's a uh
it's a hazing thing you know in a you
know not like you know sadistic way and
it was fun I mean we got a good story
out of it like when else am I gonna
drink Louis the 13th cognac was it good
it was very good it was it was yeah it
was strikingly good we have something
yeah you're owed a small bit for the
celebration yeah we should have some
right now in celebration of the DHS
leaks that came out and finally now you
want to celebrate that yeah we found out
what happened we're finally you know
covering yes everything I've been
screaming about for years came true
[Laughter]
you're gonna get a phone call from a
friend by Luke I'm sorry I was wrong
it's not a private Court Bryant Lewis
says hey Tim we have less than 20 days
worth of diesel uh is the government
holding us Hostage to vote blue or is
this career suicide less than 20 is that
where we're at because that's what some
other people were saying too it was two
days ago was at 25 according to One
Source but that could have changed in
two days I think we can we better
plastic into Diesel and we should start
doing that locally we should go uh fill
the truck up
with diesel how long does diesel stay
good I already did that and filled up my
tanks and then backup tanks does it
evaporate I did that in my I did that in
Florida too right before there was an
infrastructure attack uh but uh it could
last uh depends you know a few months I
think six months really around there
yeah but after six months what do you do
use it no but I mean like if it's if
it's if it's gone bad and it's in your
truck you can't drive it can you well I
don't know I'm not a diesel actually
this is six to 12 months then it gets
gummy yeah no no how do you rejuvenate
old diesel 50 gallons of old diesel into
the 50 gallon drum measure
three ounces of prdd or 280 yeah
yeah reconditioner
all right all right James cutberth says
justice department is busy arresting
parents as domestic terrorists while
China claims 230 000 suspects in U.S
were successfully persuaded to return to
China from April 2021 to October 2022.
wow suspects crazy
pinochet's helicopter tour says when I'm
weaker than you I ask for freedom
because that is according to your
principles when I'm stronger than UI
take away your freedom because that is
according to my principles Frank Herbert
that's right I love that guy's name Pino
shapes helicopter tours oh I was in
Chile and it's so fresh in their memory
Pinochet was like this autocratic
dictator that would take people on
helicopters and drop his political or
people he didn't like out of hell like
they just had black helicopters and
people go up they never come back they
would drop them into the ocean and stuff
it's pretty dark it's dark but uh I like
the name yeah Chili's beautiful it's so
amazing Del Mar have you ever been there
no incredible Santiago I went to see the
Capitol Building killed himself wait no
no it was the guy right before Pinochet
that killed himself in quotes he was
there and then they were like what's
that guy's name Valparaiso is also a
really really an incredible City I love
spending time down there I almost moved
to Chile I I literally I literally was
this close from from living in Chile
forever yeah greatest mining it was all
like I was like if I'm Gonna Miss This
flight I'm I'm not I'm just gonna live
here the flight the flight was delayed
and I and I waited and I did everything
and I was like whatever the the rental
car was late there there was like long
line There Was You Know problem there's
a long Security check and I'm like this
is a sign I gotta live here and then and
then and then and then I walked in like
40 minutes late to the plane and the
plane's delayed I'm like this is the
sign that means I have to go back oh I
just took it that way I was waiting for
you yeah literally because yeah not for
me but it was just a technical deal you
know the federalities are everywhere
it's all federal government there's no
local cops so like you got feds on every
not in every corner but if you make a
mistake in one area of Chile you make a
mistake in every area I just loved
Valparaiso because it was like a fishing
town and it was kind of Bohemian but it
was kind of free it was it was it was
like a San Francisco without the state
dude people were talking so highly of
Valparaiso while I was there I loved it
there it was incredible
very narrow country yeah getting narrow
yeah what's the width mile-wise
um I'm not sure but a coastline yeah not
a coastline not a coastline I've had an
idea that they could because they're
like we need more Chile they want to
make the size bigger so I was like you
can tap the volcanoes with a sieve get
the uh lava to flow down to the ocean
and to create more land like cool into
the water and then you like grow Chile
out or here's an idea give guns to your
people and then just take the land from
somewhere that's been done before I had
a Chilean girlfriend there like me too
sad I was just I had I was in a I was a
month in there and I'm like this is
amazing it's amazing I found a like a
hidden little community that was like in
the woods that the a lot of German
speakers no no that's Argentina yeah
Argentina Argentina
all right let's read some more Kane Abel
says Tim are you and Luke using Ian to
speak in code because the FBI told you
not to report the facts and truth of the
matter of the Pelosi Ian is actually
making more sense here well you know
sometimes you know Ian rolls twenties
yeah that's right he's rolling the 20s
I'm choosing to speak code on my own
that's right and code that no one
understands only Ian
beep boar beat borp
all right
shlongathan mcwinkletwat good name says
question for Luke how do you feel about
regime Libertarians actively ruining the
ideology
uh yeah yeah my favorite meme is like
the two people fighting and then the one
person uh you know with the bong
laughing and it's like libertarian
fighting a Libertarian with a
Libertarian laughing at the Libertarians
fighting each other
um I I do believe there's a lot of uh
you know what a cointel probe kind of
like Behavior inside the libertarian uh
party that has kind of made it the
larger joke that it is the the
candidates that they had within the last
few years were were just utter jokes uh
you you had the the Ghazi guy you had
the black lives matter uh woman it was
just ridiculous
um and again we shouldn't be
prioritizing a lot of this nonsense we
shouldn't try to placate black lives
matter or or the National Security State
we should just be promoting personal
responsibility just having people that
are going to be the strongest best
versions of themselves if we just
focused on you being the best version of
yourself health-wise uh physically
mentally spiritually man with that party
you know take off because there wouldn't
be a need for the party and that's
essentially what libertarianism is
according to my own opinion all right ew
says Ian Exxon made more profit last
year than in 2020 in 2021 than 20 22
2020 because covet killed demand and oil
companies took a loss in 2020 because of
it pay attention to why it happened and
how the narrative is framed please wow
interesting good news so it's four times
only because it dropped right well let's
dig into it that's right it's a record
profits and it's like is it inflation
related so I guess the best comp is what
2019 that'd be you know pre-pandemic
yeah the best years of Our Lives
all right here's a good one where is
this um
Michael krotau says quote a media
infrastructure that is accountable is
the opposite of a free press accountable
to who they the press to be accountable
to the state they want State media they
want propaganda
yep that's right
all right we'll grab just uh we'll grab
one more here we go they should be
accountable to the viewer
Eric Mercon mercone says Tom Brady was
the only player in sport ball history to
take a 60 million dollar pay cut so the
team could hire better players that's
actually a great point so one reason for
the past success over the years was that
Brady played for a substantially
sub-market contract
um you know he was the best quarterback
in the game whereas other QBs like Joe
Flacco or Drew Brees
um you know Russell Wilson you know
whoever they take these massive
contracts that cut into the salary cap
because the NFL unlike the Major League
Baseball or the NBA there's a hard
salary cap so each team can only spend a
certain amount of money when you're qb1
it's taking up a 30 million dollar per
year cap hit that really hamstrings the
rest of your roster in terms of you know
Talent acquisition so Brady uh you know
he played for I think an average of like
eight to ten million dollars a year when
he was worth 30. it helps when your wife
is you know independently wealthy so it
wasn't like he was you know missing any
meals
um but also at a certain point it's like
you're worth millions of millions of
dollars so it is it is legit that he's
doing it but it like it it's a it's a
lot different from someone who makes
like 100k being like I'm gonna go down
to 60. it's like man you're really
hurting yourself on this one you know
true it was it's cool it's cool it was
to the benefit of the team and there is
there's a counter argument so
um the NFL players Association had a lot
of beef with that because ultimately
what the NFL players union wants is to
eliminate the NFL salary cap and the
best way to do that is to make because
there's I mean that's good too deep into
this but there's there's a divide
amongst NFL owners there are some NFL
owners like the the super wealthy ones
like Jerry Jones
um who want to get rid of the salary cap
so they can be like New York Yankees and
spend 400 million dollars a year to get
the best players
um there are other owners who are
cheaper who like the salary cap because
it keeps cost down
so when someone like Tom Brady plays for
a sub-market deal he's in effect helping
the owners who want the hard salary cap
because that overall depresses the
market value for quarterbacks so in a
way yes he was helping the Patriots in
another school of thought he was hurting
the rest of the league in terms of the
players because he was artificially
depressing uh NFL salaries you think
they should keep the salary cap I don't
think so I think the best system I think
baseball has the best system in a lot of
ways because it lets teams like the
Yankees or Dodgers or Red Sox spend
whatever they want to spend to get the
best players
um and that that obviously enhances the
market for players you know it increases
their salaries because there's a pure
competitive environment I think it's a
Freer Market some would say that you
know like that hurts competition but
that's BS because like you know the the
Rays have won the World Series the
Astros I mean these are low spending
teams
um you know they do more with less while
letting the the higher cap team spend
unlimited amounts of money so it helps
everyone that's what money buy was about
the movie correct the Oakland days they
were one of those lower spending teams
um and you know Brad Pitt's character in
the movie Billy Bean um you know he
devised this or he he used this
um you know system uh sabermetrics to
try to identify better cheaper players
ah all right everybody fantastic movie
yeah if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends and
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have an excellent members only
uncensored show coming up at about 11
p.m you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
Jake do you want to shout anything out
no glad to be here guys this is awesome
yeah social media account or anything
like that people find you yeah at Jake
back at 91
j-a-k-e-b-e-q-u-e-t-t-e I am verified on
Twitter
not sure if I'm gonna pay for it but
yeah I'm on Twitter Instagram
um that's pretty much it Facebook right
on Jake that was great thank you so much
for coming on thanks for having me this
is fantastic my website is
lukeansensor.com I did a video today
about UK scientists creating a mutant
super strain of covid why well I have my
theory Lucan sensor.com also uh let's
start telling people about Twitter let's
make it the place I've been posting a
lot of pictures on there a lot of videos
on there check me out at Luke we are
change on Twitter and uh let's have some
conversations there let's do it you post
a picture of me earlier on your Twitter
page no no no no I posted a picture of
two of you of and Ian miles Chong I
guess was involved that was the wrong
one no no that was the picture of like
four of us Jake it was great meeting you
man yeah awesome thanks for letting me
hold the Super Bowl ring that's the
first one I've touched it was awesome
anytime I feel like I was there yeah
felt the power catch you later everybody
hey guys I'm sure.com I'm on Twitter too
now and I will be on there hopefully
you'll add me as a friend I was your
first follow oh that was the wrong I
made another account I didn't think I
had an account so following you now bro
hey all right everybody we'll see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out cheers